实现和管理复杂的对话系统
到课程结束时
你将能够构建出充分利用大语言模型潜力的
健壮且可扩展的对话应用
大家好
我叫viva
是一名机器人与AI专业的学生
在这门课程中
我们将全面学习land graph的基础知识
现在我假设你之前听说过蓝哥夫
所以才点击了这门课程
但我也假设你从未用LANGRAPH编写过代码
基于这个假设
我已经尽可能详细地解释了每一个知识点
这也可能意味着有时候我的讲解会比较慢
所以如果你想加快速度
随时可以调快播放速度
那么我们在这门课里会学些什么呢
首先我们会构建很多张图
很多AI智能体还会学习大量理论知识
此外我在课程中还提供了练习题
所有答案都会在GITHUB上提供
说了这么多
如果你已经准备好和我一起开启这段旅程
那就让我们进入第一部分吧
好了各位
欢迎来到本课程的第一部分
在这一部分
我们将讨论一种叫做类型注解的内容
老实说这部分完全是理论性的
但我保证它会简短而精炼
我之所以保留这一部分
是因为当我们真正开始写代码时
这些内容会在我们的AI智能体图结构和language
中频繁出现
它们会无处不在
我真的不希望大家在从未见过这些东西
或完全不知道它们是什么的情况下就开始编码
这就是为什么我会在这里讲这些内容
但我保证这部分会很短
很简洁
酷好了
让我们从字典开始
字典是一种数据结构
没错
但我之所以在这里提到它是有原因的
那么我们来看看Python中是如何描述字典的
你应该已经知道这一点
在这个例子中
我定义了一个非常简单的字典
叫做movie电影
他有两个键名称和年份
还有两个值
复仇者联盟终局之战和2019
别误会
字典确实很棒
它们允许基于唯一件高效地检索数据
而且灵活且易于实现
但它们也有一个潜在的问题
你看要确保数据符合特定结构是一个挑战
而在大型项目中
这可能会成为一个巨大的问题
简单来说
它并不会检查数据是否是正确的
数据类型或结构
而这可能会成为你项目中许多逻辑错误的根源
如果你的项目非常非常庞大
那这可能很难发现对吧
因为这是一个很小的细节
那么解决方案是什么呢
答案是使用一种叫类型字典的东西
下面是一个如何在Python中创建类型字典的例子
我想强调的是
这种类型注解在land graph中被广泛使用
它将用来定义状态
现在别担心
我们还没有讲到状态
下一节会详细讲
但请注意这一点非常重要
类型字典其实很容易实现
你只需将其定义为一个类
在这个例子中
我用的是之前展示过的同一个事例
也就是描述电影的那个键和值完全一样
它仍然有名称和年份这两个键
但要注意在这个类中
我已经明确定义了每个键对应的数据类型
比如名称是一个字符串
而年份是一个整数对吧
初始化字典时
我也做了完全相同的事情
比如复仇者联盟终局之战和2019
使用类型字典有两个主要好处
首先是类型安全性
因为我们已经明确指定了
这个数据结构中应该包含什么内容
这将大大减少运行时错误
而且代码的可读性也得到了提升
如果这个类型字典出了问题
调试也会更容易酷
那么我们现在已经讲完了类型字典
接下来我们要讲另一种类型注解联合类型union
如果你用Python编程
可能已经见过这些最新的类型注解
不过我还是会给你一个高层次的概述
联合类型union
看看这个例子
我创建了一个非常简单的函数
它接受一个值
并将其平方
在这个例子中输入X可以是整数或浮点数
联合类型union的基本含义是
无论你传入什么值
它只能是这些数据类型之一
所以在这里X只能是整数或浮点数
如果我传入五或者1.234
这完全没有问题
函数会计算平方并正常运行
但如果我传入一个字符串
比如我是一个字符串
它就会彻底失败
现在老师说是的
这个函数非常简单
如果我传入我是一个字符串
它本来也会失败
但在更复杂的应用中
希望你能看到它的实际用途
事实上
long chain和LANGRAPH的开发者在构建实际库时
广泛使用了联合类型
因此它既灵活又易于编码
并且它提供了类型安全性
因为它可以提供提示
帮助捕获错误的用法
与联合类型类似
还有另一种类型注解
那就是可选类型
Optional
可选类型与联合类型非常相似
在这个例子中
我定义了另一个函数叫做nice message
友好消息
你传入一个名字
如果你传入一个名字
他会说hi名字
例如假设名字是bob
如果我将bob传入这个函数
它会说hi bob
但如果我什么都不传入会怎样
如果我没传入任何东西
optional的作用就体现出来了
因为它表示name参数可以是字符串或者空值
如果我什么都不传
他会进入这个if语句
并说嘿随机的人
但这里还需要强调一点
它不能是其他任何东西
不能是整数布尔值
浮点数或者其他类似的东西
它必须是字符串或者空值
因为这是我在这里定义的内容库
接下来是一个叫安妮的类型注解
安妮是最容易理解的一个
它字面意思就是这个值可以是任何东西
可以是任何数据结构
在这个例子中
我创建了一个简单的函数
叫它接收一个值并打印出来
比如我传入一个字符串
它就会打印出来
而且任何东西都可以被接受
酷最后一个类型注解
我保证那就是兰姆达函数
兰姆达函数非常有用
举个例子
我现在给你两个例子
第一个例子是非常简单的例子
之前我们不是已经创建过一个square函数了吗
它接收一个值
接收一个数字
并计算它的平方
比如如果我传入square10
它会返回100
非常简单的例子
现在我再给你第二个例子这个
所以如果你有类似leaf code的背景
那你可能已经见过或者用过lambda函数
并且你肯定用过数学运算
因为它非常高效
比如如果我传入1234
这段代码的意思是
这个map函数会映射每个值
并对它执行这个操作
X乘以X结果是14916
然后将其转换回列表
莱姆达函数
实际上只是编写小型函数的快捷方式
它们让一切变得非常高效
显然这也可以用一行代码完成
但比如一个初学者可能会用for循环来实现
而更有经验的程序员可能会使用这种方式
而这显然更加高效对吧
所以希望你能开始理解这些类型
注解的强大之处
他们会在接下来的内容中出现
同样不需要记住这些内容
只需要对他们有一个高层次的理解即可
好的酷
那么我们下一节见到时候见好的完美
让我们继续
在这一节中
我们将看看land graph中的不同元素
首先从我们的第一个元素开始
这是land graph中最基础的元素之一
状态state
那么什么是状态state
它是一个共享的数据结构
存储了整个应用程序的当前信息或上下文
简单来说它就像是应用程序的记忆
Memory
记录了变量和数据节点
在执行过程中可以访问和修改这些内容
如果你还不清楚什么是节点node
别担心
接下来我们会详细讲到
这里有一个很好的类比
就是会议室里的白板
想象一下你在一个会议室里
周围还有其他参与者
每次你想出一些新东西
或者想记录一些新信息
或者更新某些信息时
你都会把它写在白板上
在这个例子中
白板充当了状态state
而参与者则是节点note
所以状态展示了整个应用程序的最新内
容或信息
希望这个解释能让你有点明白了
接下来我们来看节点node
这是land graph中的另一个基本元素
节点是图graph中执行特定任务的独立函数或操
作
每个节点接受一个输入
通常就是应用程序的当前状态
它会对输入进行处理
然后生成输出或更新状态
这里有个很好的类比
就是流水线工作站
看看这张图片
每个工作站都负责一项特定的任务
可能是安装一个零件
也可能是涂漆
检查质量等等
重点是每个工作站代表一个节点node
因为它们各自完成一项特定的任务
那么你究竟如何将这些不同的节点连接起来呢
在深入之前
我认为理解所有元素中最重要的一个至关重要
那就是图graph
它如此重要
甚至直接体现在了land graph的名字里
图只是一个总体结构
它描绘了不同任务
也就是节点是如何连接和执行的
它以可视化的方式呈现了工作流程
展示了各种操作之间的顺序和条件部分
虽然图本身很好理解
但你可以把它想象成一张路线图
在路线图上
你可以看到连接城市的路线和交叉路口
提供了下一步该走哪条路的选择
这里有一张很好的图示
这些是单独的节点
但你会发现它们之间是有某种连接的
那么它们是怎么连接的呢
这就引出了下一个元素边
edges边就是节点之间的连接
它们决定了执行的流程
他们会告诉应用程序在当前节点完成任务后
接下来应该执行哪个节点
一个非常好的类比是想象一条火车轨道
这就是火车轨道
你可以把它当作边
它连接了两个站点
一个在这里
一个在那里代表节点
并且有特定的方向
而火车会在轨道上行驶
火车就相当于你的状态
state状态会在一个站点到另一个站点之间更新
但还有一种特殊的边叫做条件编
Conditional edge
所以这其实并不复杂
理解起来很简单
它们只是专门的连接
决定了下一个要执行的节点
基于当前状态所应用的特定条件或逻辑
这里有一个非常好的类比
就是交通灯
绿色可能意味着通行
红色可能意味着停止
黄色可能意味着减速
我想表达的是这里的条件
也就是灯的颜色决定了下一步的动作
如果想更简单地理解
可以把它想象成if减else语句
话虽如此
我们继续讲下一个元素
起点
起点或起始节点是ELEGRAPH中的一个虚拟入口
它标志着工作流程从哪里开始
需要注意的是
它本身并不执行任何操作
但它作为图执行的指定起始位置
用类比来理解的话
非常简单
但如果一定要类比
可以把它当作比赛的起跑线
既然有起点
自然也需要一个终点
这就是终点元素的作用
终点节点只是表示ELEGRAPH中工作流程的结束
当应用程序到达这个节点时
图的执行完全停止
表明所有预期的流程都已经完成
同样一个好的类比就是比赛的终点线
所以目前并没有太难的内容
但接下来我们来看看工具
兔子工具是一些专门的函数或实用程序节点
可以利用它们来执行特定任务
比如他可以从API获取数据
它们通过提供额外功能
增强了这些节点的能力
一个常见的问题是工具和节点有什么区别
节点是图结构的一部分
而工具
则是节点内部使用的功能
这里有个很好的类比
就是工具箱里的工具
比如锤子用来钉钉子
螺丝刀
用来拧螺丝等等
重点是每个工具都有其独特的作用
别担心
当我们实际编写代码时
你会更详细地理解工具和节点的区别
这只是个大致概述
你可能还会问工具和节点之间有没有中间人
简短回答是有
这就是工具节点to know的作用
工具节点是一种特殊的节点
它的主要任务是运行工具
比如一个工具节点
可能是一个只负责使用工具的节点
这个工具的任务是从API获取数据
它会将工具的输出连接回状态state
以便其它节点可以使用这些信息
再回到流水线的类比
在这个例子中
可以把操作员看作工具节点
它控制机器
也就是工具
然后将所有结果传回流水线
如果我们继续深入来看一下状态图
State graph
这也是一个非常重要的元素
这将是你实际交互的第一个元素之一
它的主要作用是构建和编译图结构
所以它非常重要
它管理节点编整体状态
并确保工作流以统一的方式运行
所有数据在组件之间正确流动
所以它是一个非常重要的元素
你可以把它想象成建筑的蓝图
就像蓝图勾勒出建筑物的设计和连接一样
状态图也做了同样的事情
只是它定义了你的工作流
或应用程序的结构和流程
接下来就是可运行组件RUNNABLE登场的时候了
如果你有LAN签背景
应该对RUNNABLE很熟悉
在land graph中也非常类似
在land graph中
RUNNABLE就是一个标准化的可执行组件
用于在AI工作流中完成特定任务
它基本上充当了基础构建快的角色
让我们能够创建模块化系统
你现在可能会问RUNNABLE和节点有什么区别
简单来说
RUNNABLE可以代表各种操作
而land graph中的节点通常接收一个状态
对其执行操作
然后更新状态
如果没完全理解
也不用担心
当我们进入编码部分时
你会理解的更清楚
一个好的类比是乐高积木
就像乐高积木可以拼接在一起
建造复杂的结构一样
RNB也可以组合起来
创建复杂的AI工作流
现在我们来看看不同类型的消息
如果你有兰茜背景
你对这些会很熟悉
如果不熟悉也没关系
我们会看ELEGRAPH中最常见的五种消息类型
首先是人类消息
Human messages
它表示用户的输入AI消息
AI message表示由大语言模型生成的响应系统消息
system message用于为模型提供指令或上下文工具
消息to message类似于函数消息
但专门用于工具使用
而函数消息表示函数调用的工具
如果你之前用过像大语言模型API这样的接口
比如open night的API
这些概念会非常熟悉
尤其是系统消息
AI消息和人类消息
到这里这一部分就结束了
我们下一部分见
太棒了
现在真是令人兴奋
我们终于要开始在land graph中进行编码了
这是第一次
虽然我们已经讲完了所有理论部分
说实话这部分有点无聊
现在我们要真正开始编写一些图结构了
我们即将在本小节中编写我们的第一个图
但对于整个这一部分
我有一个小小的坦白
那就是我们不会在这部分构建任何AI智能体
为什么呢
因为我觉得我们甚至还没有真正了解
如何在land graph中编码
也没有学会如何将大语言模型
API和工具等东西结合起来
把这些东西组合在一起
可能会很混乱
有时也会让人困惑
尤其是考虑到我们以前
从未在line graph中写过代码
再说一次
就像我在课程开头提到的
这门课的目标是适合初学者
详细且全面
我们会一步步来慢慢深入
所以希望你能理解
不过别担心
我们很快就会开始编写AI智能体
目前我们只是先构建几个图
更好地理解line graph
掌握语法
学习如何编写图并变得得心应手之后
我们才会真正去构建AI智能体
好的酷
那么我们在这一部分要一起构建的图是什么呢
我称之为hello world图
主要是因为它是我们可以在LANGRAPH中编写的
最基础的图形式
目标如下
我们将理解并定义智能体状态结构
别担心你很快就会明白那是什么
我们还会创建一些简单的节点函数
就像我们在上一节讨论过的节点
并对它们进行处理和更新状态
我们将构建第一个基本的LANGRAPH结构
并理解如何编译调用和处理它
所有步骤都会涵盖
我们还会学习数据是如何通过单个节点
在连graph中流动的
这将是本节的主要目标
而本节的核心目标就是真正理解
数据是如何通过land graph中的单个节点流动的
现在先给大家提个醒
我们接下来要讲的内容是这样的
我们将要构建的就是这个图
再说一次
就像我说过的
这是你在land graph中可以构建的最基本的图形式
它有一个起点和一个终点
中间夹着一个节点
好的酷
所以希望你已经明白了我们的目标是什么
非常基础没错
我们代码部分建
好的酷
现在让我们来实际编码这个第一个图
这里我导入了三个主要的东西
dict type dict和state graph
dict和type dict
显然是字典和类型字典
而state graph则是我们之前讲过的内容
这三者是我们上一节提到的元素
所以如果这些对你来说完全陌生
我强烈建议你回去复习一下
不过你不需要记住它们具体是什么
不需要死记硬背好吧
但为了帮你回忆一下
我在这里的注释里写下了state graph是什么
可以把state graph看作是一个框架
它帮助你设计和管理应用程序中的任务流程
虽然听起来可能有点复杂
但其实并不难
一旦我们开始编码
你会觉得更有条理
现在我们要做的第一件事
就是在导入所有东西之后
创建智能体的状态
让我们称它为agent state
再提醒一下什么是状态
可以把状态看作是一个共享的数据结构
它会跟踪应用程序运行时的所有信息
好的酷
现在让我们来构建agent state
在LANGRAPH中
我们通过类来实现这一点
让我们构建一个名为agent state的类
在括号中
我们需要将状态设置为类型字典的形式
这就是为什么我们在这里指定type dict
现在让我们把它保持得非常非常基础
我们只传入一个输入
比如叫它message
显然我们要加一个冒号
并指定这个属性的数据类型
显然message的数据类型是字符串
所以我们指定为SSTR
再说一次
这只是普通的潘森
所以一旦我们完成了这些
现在就要开始编写我们的第一个节点了
这是land graph中另一个非常基础的元素
那么我们该如何定义一个节点呢
其实很简单
它就是一个普通的标准派森函数
像这样来定义
让我们先试着明确目标
假设我们要生成一条简单的问候消息
所以我们写一个名为defegrating node的函数
并传入输入
同时指定输出类型
现在我们需要指定节点的输出类型
节点的输入类型必须是状态
states输出类型也必须是状态
因为记住状态会跟踪应用程序中的所有信息
显然你需要将状态作为输入传入
并返回更新后的状态
就像这样
你传入状态
那么我们应用程序的状态是什么呢
就是我们之前定义的agent state
而输出也将是agent state
因为我们需要输出更新后的状态
我们的更新状态
在完成这个函数中的所有操作后
依然是agent state
我们在函数中执行的所有操作
都会反映在最终的状态上
好的现在我们需要做一件非常非常重要的事情
有时可能会让人觉得麻烦
但这确实是一个我希望你能养成的关键习惯
那就是文档字符串
Dog strings
在lang graph中
文档字符串非常重要
因为当我们实际构建AI智能体时
文档字符串会告诉大语言模型
这个函数的作用是什么
他的行为是什么
他具体执行什么任务
顺便说一下
创建文档字符串的方法是用三个引号
三对引号
在这个例子中
我们可以写一个简单的文档字符串
比如一个象状态添加问候消息的简单节点
那么我们现在如何引用这个消息呢
这其实只是正常的Python代码
我们会传入状态并进入message
这部分代码允许我们更新状态中的消息部分
比如说我们可以写黑加上状态中的消息
消息
我们还可以加上一些类似今天过得怎么样
这样的基本内容
现在想一想
我在这个函数里最后还需要做什么
好的
现在回想一下
几分钟前我说过
我们要返回状态或更新后的状态
而更新后的状态我们已经完成了
我们刚刚在这里对状态进行了操作
所以只需要简单地返回状态即可
酷没错
这段代码运行起来没有任何错误
好了
现在让我们实际构建这个图
这显然非常重要
那么我们该如何构建图呢
还记得我之前说过的吗
state graph是一个帮助设计和管理任务流程的框架
而这正是我们现在要做的
希望你现在能明白这一点
要在land graph中创建图
你可以使用state graph属性并传入你的状态
可以看到vs code提示了状态模式的参数描述
因此我们的状态模式其实就是我们定义的agent state
所以我们传入agent state
我还会在这里写上我们的状态模式
这样你可以直观地看到它是什么
好我们将它存储在一个叫graph的变量中
现在来了一个非常重要的方法
我们如何向这个图中添加节点
因为目前这个图还是空的
要添加节点
我们使用内置函数graph a ADD node
它需要两个主要参数
这两个参数是什么呢
vs code提示的内容看起来很复杂
其实很简单
你只需要两个参数
节点的名称和它将执行的操作
我们先给节点命名
名字可以是任何合理的值
比如叫它greater
然后vs code也提示我们需要输入操作
那么操作是什么呢
操作就是这个节点实际执行的内容
而这个节点实际执行的所有操作
都已经由这个函数定义好了
也就是grey node函数
所以只需将GRENODE函数的名字放在这里
就这样我们成功地将GRENODE添加到了图中
她的名字将是greater
记住这张图
在这张图中应该有一个起点和一个终点
我们已经完成了夹在中间的节点
但还没有真正添加起点和终点
那么我们该如何做呢
实际上有多种方法可以实现
在这个小节中
我会教你一种方法
后面再教你另一种方法
它们都很简单
你只需调用内置函数satientry point
它只有一个参数
那就是一个键
这个键就是你想让起点连接到的节点名称
想象一下起点在这里
节点在这里
显然你需要引用一个节点来创建一条边
所以你只需传入greater
同样的graph set finished point
我们也会再次传入greater
为什么
因为想象一下节点在这里
终点在这里
你需要在这两者之间建立某种连接
这就是为什么我们在这里使用greater
别担心
一旦你完成练习并继续构建更多图
你会更清楚这一点
现在最后一件事就是编译这个图
使用graph compile调用内置编译函数
可以看到这段代码运行没有任何错误
但需要注意的是
图能够成功编译
并不意味着它一定能成功运行
我的意思是
天知道当我们构建更复杂的图时
可能会有多少逻辑错误
这是一个需要注意的重要点
所以不要因为图编译通过就太高兴
可能还有逻辑错误
相信我
我知道
我想让你写一些代码来帮助你可视化这个图
你可以使用IPAD库
就像这里的代码一样
这段代码和我最初展示的第一个图非常相似
对吧
我会在这里放一张图片供你对比
唯一的区别是节点的名字
我们设置的名字是greater
为什么是greater
因为这是我们给这个节点起的名字库
看起来不错
让我们实际运行一下
要运行
你使用内置方法invoke传入消息
比如叫它bob或其他东西
我们将结果存储在一个变量中
现在我们如何获取结果的值呢
我们需要引用result
某个特定属性
现在整个图中唯一的属性就是消息
message对吧
所以我们只需写上message
完美我们得到了最终答案
嘿bob今天过得怎么样
为什么会是这样
因为这正是我们设置函数的方式
他执行的操作是先输出
嘿然后连接输入的消息
在这个例子中只是名字
接着说今天过得怎么样
我本可以把它改成任何其他内容对吧
像这样的函数几乎是无穷无尽的
但这就是整个流程的工作方式
所以希望你已经明白了如何
构建这个最初的hello world图
它非常简单
但如果你还没有完全理解
别担心
我现在会告诉你需要完成什么练习
来巩固这些知识
好的我们再练习部分再见
好了
现在是你的第一个练习时间
这个图的练习与我们刚刚做得非常相似
但我想让你创建一个个性化的
表扬智能体
你应该传入你的名字
比如bob
然后输出类似bob
你在学习land graph方面做得非常棒
给你一个小提示
你需要再次连接状态
而不是替换它
这与我们刚刚做的非常相似
而且非常基础
你应该能够完成这个练习
这只是为了让你们动手实践一下好
一旦
你完成了这个练习
加入我一起构建第二个图
我们在那里建好的
现在我们要开始构建第二个图了
正如你所看到的
它与我们构建的第一个图非常相似
只不过这次我们可以传入多个输入
就像这里显示的那样
那么在这部分中你会学到什么目标呢
我们将构建一个更复杂的智能体状态
并创建一个处理节点
用于对列表数据执行操作
现在我们将看到如何处理不同数据类型
而不仅仅是字符串
我们还将设置整个图用于处理输出
并计算这些结果
并能通过结构化输入调用图并获取输出
但在这部分内容中
我希望你能学到的主要目标是
如何处理多个输入
好的让我们开始编码
好的
现在让我们实际编写第二个图的应用程序
同样我已经导入了相同的内容
type dictionary和state graph
这次我还导入了list
但这只是一个简单的数据结构
你应该已经知道了
如果你还记得之前那个图
我们需要首先实现状态模式对吧
那么我们如何做呢
再次使用class agent state type dictionary
好吧
在继续之前提醒一下
我可以给状态模式起任何名字
甚至可以起一个完全随意的名字
比如
瓶子在这个例子中
我只是用了agent state
因为这是我学习时的习惯
现在已经成了一种习惯
但这个名字确实告诉了你
它是什么
它是智能体的状态对吧
所以我一直沿用这个名字
但再次提醒你
可以随便叫它什么酷好的
现在如果你记得构建这个图的主要目标是能够
处理和加工多个不同的输入对吧
那么我们如何实际分配它们呢
答案就在状态里
这正是我们现在要做的
记住这只是一个类型字典
所以你现在有多个键
我们来创建它们
比如说value list
整数列表
假设我们的其中一个输入是一个整数列表
我们也传入一个名字
显然它会是字符串类型
我们还定义结果为字符串完全是随机的
但现在你可以看到
我们正在处理两种不同类型的数据
整数列表和字符串
我们正在
处理三个不同的输入
values name和result
好的酷
让我们运行一下完美
现在让我们实际构建我们的节点
因为在途中
我们只会有一个节点
以保持简单记住
一步一步来让我们写deaf process values
再次思考一下这里需要什么
是的
我们需要传入状态并返回更新后的状态
那么怎么做呢
我们写state agent state
输出agent state
酷
再次养成好习惯
我知道写文档字符串很烦人
但我们还是要写
让我们写点东西
比如此函数处理多个不同的值
以及多个不同的输入库
我在这里没有特别具体
因为一来我不想花太多时间写文档
二来这里也没有大语言模型或AI对吧
这就是为什么它其实并不重要
我只是为了培养好习惯
好的现在让我们做点事情
比如把传入的整数列表求和
同时也连接名字
并将结果存储在result中
听起来不错吧
那么我们该怎么做呢
我们这样做
传入state result
因为这是我们执行操作的目标目标属性result
然后写点东西
比如嗨
接着引用名字
不你的总和等于我们直接使用内置的Python函数
Sum
传入state values库
最后显然我们要返回状态
完美这就完成了好了
现在我们实际创建图
它会非常非常类似于上一节的内容
因为再次
只有一个节点
一个起点和一个终点
所以像上次一样
我们使用state graph初始化图
并传入我们的状态模式
也就是agent state
然后将它存储在变量graph中
好的让我们添加节点graph
Eddy node
再次记住它需要两个参数名称和操作
在这个例子中
名称就叫
processor吧
当然你可以随便命名而操作
由这个函数执行对吧
Processor values
所以我们只需
添加它好的
我已经告诉过你如何初始化起点和终点
这只需要那段代码
将入口点连接到节点
在这个例子中是一个节点
也就是processor节点
同样的方式适用于终点
然后使用graph compile编译
花点时间想一下
你觉得这个图会是什么样子
再次强调它非常非常类似于之前的图
唯一的区别是节点的名字
我们这次叫它processor
好的
现在让我们实际测试一下
调用这个图
怎么做呢
我们使用invoke函数
这里有一个重要的部分
这是一个常见的错误
我犯过很多次
确保将编译后的图存储在一个变量中
因为如果你直接写graph invoke
这是没有意义的
因为你
还没有编译图
这就是为什么你需要使用app调用
这就是为什么我也在这里用了app t
如果我不这么做
graph get graph会完全乱套对吧
因为你的图还没有编译
所以当我使用app get graph时
流程才正常运行库
现在让我们再次存储结果
比如as as等于软件invoke库传入一些值
比如说values
让我们传入一个整数列表
我只是为了证明一个观点
还没有尝试制作一个复杂的图
然后传入名字
比如STEVE
好的酷
让我们打印答案
看看会发生什么完美
现在你可以看到你的值是1234
你的名字是STEVE
结果是hi steve
你的总和等于十
为什么会这样
因为这正是
我们要求节点执行的操作输出嗨
然后是名字
这里是斯蒂夫总和等于值的总和
1+2加3+4=10对吧
这就是我们得到这个答案的原因
那么如果我只想访问result不想要
其他
多余的内容怎么办
要做到这一点
你可以再次明确指定result
你会以更简洁的方式得到它
酷现在我想再尝试一件事
只是为了进一步加深你的理解
让我们加一些打印语句
这里放一个print state
然后执行操作
再在这里打印状态
这只是为了展示状态是如何更新的
应该很容易理解
因为这是非常基础的代码
同样在操作前打印状态
在操作后打印状态
就这样库看value等于
1234name等于STEVE
这是我们传入的输入
注意我没有将results作为输入传入
我本可以这么做
但LANGRAPH会自动将其设置为一个空值
如果你没有传入输入的话
这里需要注意
如果我在这里也使用了state result来更新state result
比如用state result更新它自己或别的东西
那么你会遇到问题
因为你的state result已经被初始化为空值
因为你没有将它作为输入传入
所以要
小心这一点
但在这种情况下
他能工作
因为我们只是给state result赋值
而不是用它来赋值别的东西
它被正确赋值了库
你可以看到在操作完成后
也就是你的操作被执行
并且内容被连接后
你可以看到结果在这里
这正是我们在清理之前得到的结果
库
希望你能理解这一点
它应该非常直观且易于解读
但为了进一步巩固你的理解
我们再做一些练习
完成练习后
我在练习部分等
你好的
欢迎来到你的第二个练习
在这个练习中
我希望你创建一个
传入单个整数列表
名字和操作的图
如果操作是加号
就将元素相加
如果是乘号
就将所有元素相乘
这些都在同一个节点内完成
不要创建额外的节点
例如输入可以是jack
sparrow值为1234操作是乘法输出格式
因为hijack sparrow
你的答案是24
给你一个小提示
要实现这样的功能
你需要在节点中使用if语句
稍微复杂一点
但
整个概念是一样的
完成这个练习后
我会在我们构建第三个图的时候再见
你好的
到时候见
欢迎来到你的第三个图
这次我们要做什么呢
已经处理了多个值和其它内容
让我们让图变得更复杂一些
这就是为什么我们要构建一个顺序图
它的意思是我们将创建并处理多个节点
这些节点可以按顺序处理
和更新状态的不同部分
我们将学习如何通过边将节点连接在一起
并调用图
真正看到状态如何
随着我们在途中的逐步推进而变化
所以你的主要目标应该是理解如何在land graph中
创建和处理多个节点
听起来不错吧
好的
我在代码部分等你
现在我们要开始编写第三个图
我们的进展相当快
做得很好
同样输入是相同的
state graph和type dictionary
完美像我们之前做的
两个图一样
我们将首先编码状态模式或智能体状态
所以我们写class agent state
再次需要以
type dedictionary的形式编写
在这个例子中
我们有三个属性都是字符串类型
因为我们已经知道如何处理多种数据类型
所以保持简单name字符串级字符串和final字符串
好的
现在我们要构建的是两个节点函数
它们就是执行的操作
同样你只需简单地写第一个
我在这里叫它first node
正如我之前提到的
我们传入
状态并返回更新后的状态
好的养成好习惯
加上文档字符串
这是序列中的第一个节点
好的
在这个特定的节点中
我们想做什么
我只是想操作final部分
比如说state final
等于state
或者我们可以用F减string写f state name
比如high库
然后直接返回状态
完美
现在我们再次创建一个新节点state
Agent state
返回它
完美
我直接复制这个文档字符串并稍作修改
这是第二个节点完美
为了加快速度
在这个例子中
我也想让state final等于state new ur stage
年老了
这是一个非常简单的例子
易于理解
所以我把它设计得很基础
虽然它不会解决世界性难题
但它会帮助你理解
不过这里有一个我故意留下的逻辑错误
我希望你能尝试找出它
好的
这里的逻辑错误是当我们构建完图并运行后
我们会对传入的名字说嗨
比如传入查理
我们会说嗨查理
并将它存储在final属性中
这是我们想要的
但问题出现在
我们进入第二个节点时
我们再次更新了state final
你可以这样做
你可以在任何节点中与这些属性交互
也可以多次操作
但注意这里发生了什么
我们完全替换了之前的内容
还记得我们有嗨查理吗
现在我们完全用你年龄岁替换了它
但我们希望保留两者的内容
那么如何保留两者呢
在此我们只需将它们连接起来
可以写成
state加state file
就这样
逻辑错误应该解决了
因为我们现在连接了state final
本质上只是添加到之前的内容上
保留了之前的内容对吧好的
现在让我们进入有趣的部分
如何实际构建这个图
其实它与之前的两个图非常相似
除了有一个新东西
我们需要学习像往常一样
我们使用state graph
启动框架agent state
然后将其存储在graph中
我本可以将变量命名为其他名称
任何东西我只是习惯性地叫它graph
因为它直观上更容易理解
好的
现在我们添加节点
所以写graph a ADD node
为了简单起见
我直接用函数的名字作为节点的名字好吧
这样更容易理解
所以graph denode
然后是第二个节点
第二个节点库好的
现在我们已经添加了两个节点
显然我们需要设置入口点和终点对吧
所以我们设置入口点
像这样设置入口点非常直观
因为我们想连接到第一个节点
而不是第二个节点对吧
所以应该是起点
第一个节点
第二个节点终点
但你可能已经在想
我们如何把第一个节点和第二个节点
连接起来呢
如果你记得或回忆起之前的内容
理论部分提到过
在land graph中有一个叫做边的元素
这正是我们现在要做的
我们将使用编
这就是我刚才提到的新内容
你们即将学到的
那么怎么用呢
很简单
用graph edge
如果可以的话
完美同样很简单
你用start key和key类似于入口点
但在这种情况下
你需要
传入两个参数
我们要的边是在第一个节点和第二个节点之间
对吧
这正是我们在这里传入的
第一个节点和第二个节点像之前一样
我们将终点设置在第二个节点
并编译这个图
现在想想这个图会是什么样子
花点时间思考一下
像这样
起点终点这两个节点夹在中间
但现在有一条边
如果我要特别挑剔的话
应该叫它
有向边
因为数据或状态更新的流向
是从第一个节点到第二个节点对吧
库现在我们已经完成了这个图
让我们再次调用它
我已经准备好了代码
让我们调用它
传入参数
比如查理
然后传入年龄为20库
打印结果完美
除了这里的对齐问题
我可以马上调整一下
完美好了
现在你可以看到
它显示嗨charlie
你今年20岁
显然我们可以将所有这些操作
放在一个节点中完成
就像我们在前一节中做过的那样
但我们的目标显然是能够创建多个节点
并处理状态的逐步变化
所以你学到的一个重要东西显然是
如何使用ADD edge方法
另一个你巩固的概念是
你可以在任何时候更改状态中的这些键值
只要你想就可以多次修改
比如这里我们传入了state final
在这里实现了state final
又在第二个节点中实现了state final
如果我们有更多的节点
我们可以一遍又一遍地这样做
我们也学到了如何避免一个常见的逻辑错误
有时候很多人不小心替换了一个属性中的内容
这会导致很多逻辑错误
所以一定要小心这一点
是的
这又是一个相对简单的例子
不难
希望我接下来要给你的练习能巩固这一点酷
那我
在练习部分等你
太棒了
现在我们将进入第三个图的练习
我希望你基于我们刚刚
讲过的内容进行扩展
这次不是两个节点
而是要构建三个节点
仍然是按顺序排列
别搞得太复杂
你需要接受用户的姓名
年龄和技能列表
第一个节点专门用于个性化名字字段
并加上问候语
第二个节点描述用户的年龄
第三个节点列出用户的所有技能
并以格式化字符串呈现
然后你需要将这些信息合并并存储在result
字段中输出
这是一个组合消息
我希望你输出的格式是这样的
比如说名字是LINDA
输出应该是LINDA
欢迎来到系统
你今年31岁
你拥有以下技能
Python机器学习和line graph
好的这是练习的一个提示
你需要使用ADD方法两次
这将真正巩固你对如何构建图的理解
好的酷
完成之后
所有的练习答案都会在GITHUB上提供
一旦你交叉检查并确认自己做对了
我会在下一节见你
我们将构建第四个图
好的到时候见
欢迎欢迎欢迎好的
我对教你们这个图特别兴奋
第四张图
为什么
因为我们将学习如何构建条件图
这是我们第一次实现条件逻辑
当然我们在之前的练习中也做过
但那是在单个节点内完成的
这次我们将学习如何在整个图中实现条件逻辑
在整个图结构中
我们将实现条件逻辑
来引导数据流向不同的节点
我们会使用起点和
终点节点来管理入口和出口点
我们再次使用多个节点来执行不同的操作
比如加法和减法
并且能够
创建一个路由节点来处理决策并控制图的流程
所以主要目标是让你了解
如何使用这个内置函数
它允许你在land graph中创建条件
编好的激动人心的内容
我在代码部分等你
好了
现在让我们实际编写代码吧
你会发现输入这次略有修改
仍然是type dictionary和state graph
但这次我还导入了起点和终点
如果你还记得几小节前我说过
有多种方法可以初始化起点和终点
这是另一种方式
可以说这是更简单的方式
但我不太在意哪种方式更好
不过无论如何
我会教你们两种方法
好吧好的
让我们成功导入这些内容
按照标准流程
我们先设计再编码状态模式
也就是class agent state
再次使用
Type dictionary
在这种情况下
我希望能够传入两个数字和一个操作
比如加法或减法操作
这两个操作中的一个
当然我可以将所有这些都放在一个节点中完成
但这不是重点
我故意让它非常非常简单
所以你要学习的主要概念是如何
实现条件逻辑好的
那么让我们编写所需的各个键值
number one是整数
operation是字符串
比如加号或减号
Number two
也是整数
final number也是整数
final number是对两个数字进行加法或减法的结果
够简单了吧
我们已经
做过很多次了
好的现在有趣的部分来了
提前说一下
刚开始可能不会完全明白
但当我们从整体上回顾
本小节的所有代码时
一切都会开始清晰起来
所以一开始可能不太明白
但没关系
回头看时就会明白了
好的
让我们创建第一个节点函数
叫它艾特
它仍然是一个节点
我们
输入状态模式并返回更新后的状态模式
文档字符串也一样
但这次我直接从这里复制它
准确地说明了它的功能
这个节点会将数字相加
很简单
state final number等于state number one
加上state
Number two
然后我们直接返回状态
很简单吧
就像我们处理加法一样
我们也需要一个节点来处理减法
所以DFSUBTRACTOR我已经实现了
它这样就不浪费时间了
这个节点会将两个数字相减
与之前的节点函数非常相似
只是他做的是减法
当然你可能会问
如果number one小于number two怎么办
结果会是负数
这并不重要
我们的主要目标还是实现初始逻辑
而不是每个节点的内部工作原理
好的
现在我们构建了另一种类型的节点
并以相同的方式初始化它
但这次我们叫这个节点
Decide next node
给它一个能说明其功能的名字对吧
所以再次使用state agent state
并像这样传递参数
完美好的文档字符串可以写成这个节点
将选择图的下一阶段
或者应该说是图的下一个节点
我们现在使用if语句
在写代码之前
让我们先尝试
规划一下它是如何工作的
这个特定节点会位于图的起点
所以我们会有起点节点
还会有这个特定的
节点我们可以叫它路由器router
因为根据当前状态模式的内容
它会将数据路由到下一个节点
我会马上放一张图片
这样你会更容易理解我的意思
但我们本质上会让路由器
决定是加两个数字还是减两个数字
而这显然会由operation属性决定
你应该从这里能看到好的
现在让我们来编写代码
这是最难的部分
If state operation
如果我能拼对的话
等于等于加号
好的
如果state operation等于加号
我们需要做一些事情
将它传递给下一个节点
好吧
你的第一
各猜测可能是好吧
我猜就是调用这个函数对吧
不完全是在蓝GRAFF中
你实际上返回的是边
我们还没有描述
编呢对吧
但现在我只说这条边的名字是audition operation
同样如果是减法
我们会这样做
所以再次强调
我们会根据状态模式中的operation值
如果是加号
我们就调用相应的边
返回边
Addition operation
如果是减法
我们同样使用subtraction operation编
不过我们还没有定义这两条边
这就是我刚才说的
当我们稍后从整体上回顾时
在构建完所有内容后
一切都会更有意义
所以现在请耐心跟着我运行成功
现在我们来构建图
这是最令人兴奋的部分
像往常一样
我们使用state graph来创建图框架
所以graph等于这个
让我们把这些节点添加到我们的途中
graph d node就叫它router吧
同样我们会传入d decide next node
完美
现在我要坦白一件事
我知道这不会工作
我还没构建完图的其他部分
但最终这确实不会工作
这里有一个微妙的原因
主要是这一行AD d node
Router decide next node
问题出在decide next node上
因为
你可以看到当我们按下decide next node时
文档字符串出现了
但这不会工作的原因是仔细看看这三个函数
我们在这两个函数中做了什么
而在第三个函数中没有做
给你一点时间分析一下
好的没关系
如果你没看出来
也不用担心
正确答案是
我们在前两个函数中返回了更新后的状态
但在
这个节点中我们没有这么做
我们只是返回了边
这是一个细微的区别
我知道
但这就是land graph的工作方式
你很快就会明白为什么他们这样做
那么现在我们怎么处理这个问题呢
我当然可以先构建这个图
然后让你看到错误
但那样事情会变得一团糟
这就是为什么我一开始就告诉你
为什么这不会工作
现在你知道了
为什么它不工作
那怎么修复呢
很简单
你使用这样的代码
Lambda state state
如果你之前用过lambda函数
这很容易理解
如果没用过
不用担心
这只是说你的输入状态将作为输出状态
用更简单的话来说
把它看作是一个直通函数
也就是说你的输入状态会被传递
你的状态会被输入
而输出将是完全相同的状态
为什么是完全相同的状态
因为你
根本没有改变状态
你在这里做的是比较操作
但并没有赋值
比较和赋值是有区别的对吧
同样的
在这个函数中
你只是
检查操作是否是减号
但完全没有进行任何复制操作
事实上这个状态根本没有发生任何变化
这就是为什么我们可以
把它当做一个直通函数
希望这能说得通好了
继续前进
别担心你会得到更多练习的
这是你第一次看到这个
接下来我们将添加编
这和上次的一样
普通的编我们需要起点键
Start key
这里是不同的初始化方式
还记得我们以前用set entry point和set finish point吗
我们现在不用这些了
而是用start关键字
因为我们导入了它
确保如果用这种方式的话
要导入start和end
你的起点将是start point
那么
你想让起点连接到哪里呢
我们希望它连接到RT
如果我把它用引号括起来
为什么不直接连接到加法节点或减法节点呢
再想想回看一下我刚才展示的图
如果我们把起点
直接连接到加法节点或减法节点
那么路由器的意义何在
关键在于路由器决定输入是什么
然后从那里分支到正确的节点
这就是为什么
路由器需要是我们连接起点的第一个节点
酷完美
现在我们添加并实现本节要学习的新内容
Graph add conditional edge
所以graph ADD conditional edges看起来很复杂
但实际上比看上去要简单得多
第一部分是原节点
你可以在这里看到
源节点就是节点的名字
我们希望条件边从哪个节点开始
当然是路由器节点对吧
那就是原部分完美
如果你看这里
他问你要执行的路径是什么
在我们实现路径之前
显然需要告诉他要执行的操作是什么
这就是这个节点的作用
decide next node的部分
所以我们把它作为第二个参数传入
这就是路径
现在我们要实现所谓的路径映射
你应该已经在这里简要看到了
路径映射我们已经实现了源
也就是路由器实现了路径
也就是你的decide next node函数
不用纠结于hash burnb
这些东西真的不需要过度复杂化
现在是时候实现路径映射了
路径映射将以字典的形式呈现
记得我之前提到的addition operation和subtraction operation吗
它们是边
现在我们要实现它们
所以我们要在这里创建两条新编
让我先为你写好代码
然后你会明白的给我一秒钟
好了就是这样
那么这段代码到底是什么意思呢
它以边和节点的形式呈现
这条边的起点显然是这个路由器节点
它告诉我们它会连接到哪里
当你看到实际的图时
会更容易理解
别担心
现在只需知道加法操作和减法操作是编的名字
而两个
节点分别是加法节点和减法节点
对吧好的
最后我们来到了需要创建终点的部分
显然如果你回头看这张图
我嗯
刚刚展示在屏幕上
你会发现我们需要两条边连接到终点
我们需要一条边从
加法节点出发
另一条边从减法节点出发
我们可以这样添加两条边
graph ado对决
起点是加法节点
然后终点是终点节点
同样地从减法节点到终点节点
接着编译这个图
app等于graph compile
酷没有错误
现在最激动人心的部分来了
再次尝试想象一下这个图会是什么样子
应该像这样
可能和你最初预期的略有不同
但没关系
我们再次有了一个起点
一个路由器
还有两个节点
加法节点和减法节点
注意记得我说过
加法操作和减法操作是编的名字吗
就是这里加法操作和减法操作
他们告诉我们该往哪个方向走
我们怎么去加法节点
用加法操作
我们怎么去减法节点
用减法操作
然后显然我们创建这两条边来连接到终点
太棒了
我们会再次从整体上回顾
但现在让我们实际调用这个图看看会发生什么
所以让我们使用这段代码
他的意思是将number one定义为十
operation定义为减号
number two定义为五
因为我们用了减法
最终结果应该是十
减五等于五
我们打印了结果
答案就是这样
number one等于十
operation等于减号
number two等于五
final number是五
显然我调用的方式和之前略有不同
这是另一种调用方法
好的不难
但让我们再复习一遍
巩固一下
我们导入了所有东西
用agent state和type dictionary创建了状态模式
然后我们创建了三个不同的节点
加法节点
减法节点和决定下一个节点的路由器
在这个decide next node中
你可以看到
如果操作是加号
它会进入加法操作边
也就是这条边如果是减法操作
它会进入这边
这就是我们如何构建图
我们添加了节点
添加了从起点到路由器的边
然后添加了条件边
这是我们本节学到的新内容
我们引用了路由器
并使用了边节点格式
边是加法操作到加法节点
然后是减法操作到减法节点
从视觉上看就是加法操作到加法节点
减法操作到减法节点
我知道这一开始会让人有点困惑
别担心
我也花了一段时间才理解这个
好的
那我们在练习部分再见吧
太棒了
让我们来看看这个图的练习是什么
你需要构建这个庞然大物
乍一看它看起来很吓人
但如果你仔细分析一下
其实它只是我们刚才编写的内容
重复了两次
我们需要把这个表示成一个庞然大物
并且需要把这些都表示成庞然大物
并且需要复制一次
本质上你需要输入四个数字和两个操作
并输出最终结果
例如number one number
Two number
Three
number four和对应的操作及结果
在这种情况下
我们需要计算10-5=5
7+2=9
这两个数字应该被输出
我之所以给你这个练习
是因为它会真正巩固你对条件编的理解
这对接下来的几个图和我们即将构建的AI
智能体非常重要
好的完成之后
通过查看并对照GITHUB上的答案
我会在下一张图中等你
好的干得好
我们几乎快到这一节的尾声了
我们将要构建最后一个图
也就是第五张图
现在我们已经学到了很多
关于LANGRAPH及其内部机制的知识
这将对我们下一节中
最终构建你期待的AI智能体提供很大帮助
本小节中我们将学习一个重要概念
还有一个我们尚未学习的概念
那就是循环
所以我们要创建一个简单的循环图
这次的目标非常简单
目标不多
主要是实现涉及循环的逻辑
将数据流
回传到节点
并创建一条条件边
这你已经在前一节学过了
不过关于练习
请务必完成那个练习
那可能是到目前为止最难的一个练习
所以别担心
如果你没做出来也没关系
如果你做出来了
说明你做得非常好
如果你没做出来
可以看看GITHUB
试着对比一下自己哪里出错了
记住在line graph中构建图的方式不止一种
确保图是正确构建的
并且能够正常运行
如果你想进一步扩展
可以尝试让它更加健壮好了
回到正题
这是最后一张图
我保证主要目标是编写循环逻辑
那么废话少说
让我们为这一节编写最终代码吧
太棒了
这是我们为这一节要编写的最终代码开始了
这是第五张图的代码
这次我会采取稍微不同的方法
直接向你们展示我们最终要构建的图
从现在开始
这样做是有原因的
这样可以帮助我们养成良好的习惯
原因是当你完成这门课程后
无论是为自己还是为客户开发AI智能体系统
比如打造你自己的贾维斯系统或其它东西
你显然需要规划它是如何工作的
对吧
你需要思考我需要哪些节点
需要哪些边
这个边是否需要是条件边
起点和终点放在哪里等等
你可以通过纸笔或软件
比如我用的来做这些
关键是你需要某种蓝图
这其实也是行业中的常见做法
你显然会先有一个蓝图
然后根据蓝图编写图
就像UI设计师渲染他们的UI设计
然后交给软件开发人员去实现应用一样
这就是我想和你们一起培养的习惯好了
这是我希望在这一节中构建的图
显然会有起点和终点
而这张图
大部分应该都很熟悉
除了这个循环部分
我们将创建一个简单的问候节点
和另一个叫随机节点的部分
在状态中用户输入他们的名字
输出应该是简单的害你的名字
然后图进入随机节点
在这个随机节点中
我想要
生成五个随机数
提前说明一下
是的
这张图在工业应用中完全没有意义
我知道
但我故意把它简化了
以便让你们掌握基本概念
像这样的循环完全可以避免
比如改成for循环对吧
比如我可以在
这个节点中使用一个for循环运行五次
来生成这些数字
我明白这一点
但为了让大家真正理解这个概念
我故意让它保持简单好的
继续我们的常规输入
唯一的区别是这次我还导入了软的模块
如果你之前用过潘森
应该对这个库很熟悉了吧
好的
让我们从agent state开始
Class agent state type dictionary
我们需要的第一件事是什么
让我们看看有起点
问候节点需要任何键值吗
不需要
对于问候节点
我说过
我希望用户能够
输入它们的名字
所以我们需要一个name属性或键
然后对于随机数节点
我们需要某种形式的列表来存储这些数字
所以是number list int完美
还有一件事
看看这个循环我们怎么知道什么时候
停止呢我们需要某种计数器对吧
counter int完美
当然提前说明一下
当你真的开始制作你的AI智能体时
你不可能一开始就完全知道需要哪些属性
除非你是极其有经验的人
但大多数情况下你不会一开始就全知道
不过没关系
通过不断实践
你会逐渐更好的推测需要哪些属性
你也可以进行迭代开发对吧
好的太棒了
现在让我们实际构建这些节点吧
先从问候节点开始
我们通常如何定义一个函数
Def grating node
显然需要agent states
像这样完美
文档字符串我已经有了
所以不用再写了
我知道有点无聊
但这是好习惯
现在让我们更新name键怎么做呢
你应该已经知道了
state name等于嗨那里state name完美
接下来我输入一个名字
并将其替换为嗨那里
这个人现在让我们在这里初始化
计数器变量为什么我要这么做
让我先写下来再解释
显然我正在更改某些设置
比如值
所以我需要传入一个有效的整数作为初始值
当我传递值时
必须确保它是一个有效的整数
调用图对吧
但问题是
如果我传入二作为计数器的初始值会怎样
如果没有这行代码
它会一直递增
直到达到五
因为我需要五个数字
但如果从二开始
最终会给我七个数字
这显然不够健壮对吧
所以这基本上会清除用户输入的任何无效整数
如果他们输入零
那好我们将其替换为零
如果他们输入-20
因为他们贪心或其他原因
我们也会确保将其重置为零
这只是为了让它更健壮
就这样返回状态好了
接下来让我们
创建第二个节点
也就是随机节点
我们可以说random al state
Agency
State
Agent state
完美文档字符串再次派上用场了
我保证在下一节会有
用这个函数生成一个从0~10的随机数
这段代码本质上是将生成的随机数
添加到数字列表中
这就是它的全部功能
我们在这个节点还需要做什么
我们需要递增计数器的值对吧
C加等于一
这会将值增加一
然后我们
返回状态好了
现在我们来看看如何实现循环逻辑
这里提醒一下
请仔细听
在任何软件开发程序或语言中
编写应用程序的方式不止一种对吧
LANGRAPH也一样
有多种
不同的方式来编写像这样的循环逻辑
我会向你们展示其中一种方法
我显然不能展示所有方法
因为时间有限对吧
但显然你练习得越多
就会找到更高效的方法
我即将展示的方法
也非常高效
别担心
现在你可能猜到
我要创建一个类似路由器节点的东西
接近了
但我不会创建另一个路由器
节点你可以看到图中假设客户想要这张图
客户不希望这里再有一个路由器节点
那么我们怎么处理呢
我们可以创建一个条件边怎么做呢
好吧
让我们开始写一个新的函数
比如def should continue state
Agent state
让我们创建这个决定下一步操作的函数
类似于这样好了
现在我们在这里设置循环逻辑
这应该看起来
很熟悉了吧
完美让我们运行一下
那么我在这里写了什么
如果计数器值小于五
因为我们从零开始对吧
这就是五个值
我还写了一个打印语句
这样我们可以跟踪进度
每当我写代码时
当你和我一起编码或做
练习时打印语句非常有用
可以在每个地方都加上打印语句
或者也可以使用断点
这样你就知道代码
在哪失败了
如果失败的话好了
这里我们返回循环边和退出编
显然我们有循环边
这是
退出编到目前为止
一切按计划进行
但到目前为止是关键
你永远不知道对吧
提前说明一下
我想向你们展示一下
这是轨迹应该如何运行
我们从问候节点开始
为什么
因为我们显然要从起点到问候节点
然后进入随机节点
并且进出随机节点五次
为什么是五次
因为我们想要五个随机数对吧
到那时这个if语句会无法满足条件
也就是说它会失败
于是我们会进入else语句并返回退出
如果我们返回退出
就会进入终点节点
好的终点节点
这就是大致的过程好了
让我们快速构建这张图
你应该知道如何初始化图
Agent graph
让我们
添加这些节点
我们有两个节点
一个是问候节点
一个是随机节点
正是我们想要的对吧
问候节点和随机节点完美
好了
现在我们要添加一条边
在问候节点和随机节点之间
为什么
因为我创建了这条边
你看这条边问候节点和随机节点之间的这条边
就是我创建的那条边
好了
现在我要创建条件编
这是通过这里完成的
我也在这里写了一些注释
这里是原节点
也就是随机节点条件边从这里开始
然后是路由函数或这里的数
我
其实应该写成action
因为这是我们想要执行的操作底层机制或函数
我们将用它来决定使用哪条边
这由输的continue函数实现对吧
再次注意这两条边是相同的边
如果是循环边
那就是这里
输出后我们需要回到随机节点
这是我们生成并放置的节点
如果不满足条件
我们就进入终点部分
显然我们还需要设置入口点
同样你不需要在这里设置出口点或终点
因为我们已经
通过这里的end完成了完美
然后我们只需编译图
app等于graph compile
好的编译成功了
这是个好兆头
但让我们
看看我们的图是否完全一致
我会把图的图片放在这里
这样就不用来回滚动了
但你可以
看到我们有起点和终点
有问候节点和随机节点
还有两条条件边
我们实现了循环回到随机节点以及退出边
正如我们想要的
花点时间对比一下
好了继续
好的
现在我有这段代码
我输入了我的名字
一个全新的列表
并将计数器设置为一
正如你
所见它进入了循环一循环二循环三循环四
因为这些是打印语句
打印结果显示hi那里VIVO这是我的名字
数字十二十二六
这些都是随机生成的
你可以看到计数器值是五
记住我之前说的
我们将计数器值设置为零
以使其更健壮
如果我们没有这样做
它会生成六次
现在我可以将其设置为负100
它仍然会给我不同的随机值
但代码基本上是一样的
这就是我个人在LANGRAPH中创建循环的方式
很简单对吧
但显然随着练习
你可能会找到其他方法
如果你找到了
请务必
告诉我再次强调不止一种方法
你可以在link in或INSTAGRAM上给我发消息
随便哪个都可以
所以这终于
是我们为本节最后一张图实现的代码
请完成图五的练习
我们应该就可以开始制作AI智能体了
那么我在练习代码里等你
太棒了
好的干得好
现在是最后一个图的练习
你需要实现右边的这个图
你需要实现一个自动化的更高或更低
游戏背景是这样的
你需要设置一个范围
我们可以猜1~20之间的整数
当然图必须不断猜测
最大猜测次数是七次
如果猜对了就停止
如果没有
我们继续循环
直到达到最大限制七次
请注意
我们不需要传递任何输入
实际的图应该能够自行猜测
因此完全没有人工干预
每次猜测一个数字时
提示节点
也就是这个节点应该说更高或更低
图需要根据这些信息进行调整并
相应的猜测下一个数字
例如输入应该是类似玩家名字
students猜测应该是一个空列表
因为我们正在初始化列表
尝试次数应设置为零
下限和上限应为1~20
我之所以将这些作为输入传递
是因为如果你想扩展到
比如1~50的数字或者其它范围
也很容易做到
所以这里有个提示
每次猜测后需要根据提示调整范围
一旦你完成了这个练习
你将完全巩固对ELEGRAPH中循环的理解
完成后请对照GITHUB上的答案
我会在下一节等你
我们终于要开始制作AI智能体了
再见
好的再见
好的大家好
欢迎回到这一全新章节
我们将真正开始学习AI智能体
现在我们终于在land graph的能力上进行了升级
我也升级了我的穿衣品味
其实并没有
但这确实是个令人兴奋的时刻
因为我们终于要开始制作AI智能体了
我们将在本章节中制作许多AI智能体
从第一个智能体开始
严格来说它并不是一个智能体
但我这么命名是因为听起来很酷
虽然实际上不是
但让我们看看我们将在本小节中学到什么
我们要构建一个简单的机器人
就是这样
这些是我们的目标
我们将定义一个状态变量
一个状态结构
其中包含一个human message对象的列表
我在课程早期曾简要提到过
什么是human message
顾名思义
它是由人类
也就是我们提供给AI的消息提示
我们将使用land chain的chattle pen i库
初始化g p t-4.0模型
我们将发送和处理不同类型的消息
构建并编译智能体的图
但主要目标是如何
将大语言模型集成到我们的图中
那么我们最终要构建的图是什么样子的呢
非常非常简单
它看起来像这样是的
它看起来完全像我们最初制作的第一张图
但
功能显然会有所不同
因为我们现在正在集成大模型
令人兴奋的内容来了好了
那我们在代码部分再见好了
开始编码时间
我们现在先写第一个AI智能体
也就是最简单的那个
我已经导入了所有必要的库
这样我们就不浪费时间了
你一边写代码一边复制时
我也会简单解释一下这些是什么
让我们保持在同一水平上
我们之前已经多次导入过type dictionary和list
但这两个还没导入
Lunching cooda messages
Import human message
我在本节开头提到过
什么是human message
这就是我们获取它的库
同样我们要用OpenAI的大语言模型
所以会从兰茜的OpenAI库中使用卡头
peni land graph图结构我们都很熟悉了
这个是DOTONV文件
有几个点要说明
你可能会想等等
不是说要做land graph吗
怎么这里出现蓝浅的东西
你要知道land graph是建立在LANCH之上的
而lantern本身已经有很成熟的库了
那为什么不直接用呢
这就是land graph的设计方式
利用LANCH提供的强大且成熟的库
我不是叛徒
我们还是在做land graph的内容
同时也在借助land cha的优势
没问题的
现在这个DOTV文件如果你没接触过也没关系
它就是一个用来存储敏感信息
比如AAPI密钥或配置值的文件
主要是出于安全考虑
我自己的都腾威文件放在项目文件夹里
这样你就看不到我的软件密钥
否则我就破产了
你现在可能还会问
为什么我们需要API密钥
因为我们调用的是外部大语言模型
如果我们用本地部署的大模型
比如通过欧拉玛就不需要API密钥
而是直接用欧拉玛的集成库
因为我们用的是HTTPT
所以必须要有AAPI来跟他的服务通信
我们用一个简单的Python代码加载ENV文件
现在我们都在同一水平线上了
开始写我们的AI智能体吧
首先定义状态
像平时一样
这次class agenstate type dictionary完美
那么在这个状态里我们需要什么属性呢
其实只有一个messages部分
它应该是human message列表的形式
因为当我们调用图时
输入的就是人类消息
为了让大语言模型知道这是人类发的消息
我们需要明确标注为human message类型
好的
现在我们初始化大语言模型
LM等于chat open i
然后指定我们想要的模型
我选的是GPT付四欧没错
还有ANTHROPIC的chat模型
也有欧拉玛的蓝
Chen
提供了很多内置库
很棒
我个人常用切头pine
也经常用CHEETHROPIC
我觉得切头pine特别好用
很简单
我也试过用CHALLAMA
但集成到LANGRAPH时有点麻烦
所以我选了OpenAI
如果你担心费用
别担心非常便宜
如果你想省钱
也可以用g p t-4欧解mini模型
不过说实话成本极低
比如每千个词源的输入输出费用大概几毛钱
真的非常便宜
现在我们来定义节点函数
process显然要传入状态并返回状态
完美
那么我们怎么调用大语言模型呢
lunching和LANGUPH团队都喜欢用invoke这个词
你可能注意到调用图的时候
我们用了invoke运行大语言模型时也用invoke
好我们先把响应结果存到变量里
Lm invoke
我们要调用什么
从提示里可以看到
他要求一个language model input
其实就是你想让大语言模型做什么
你的问题是什么
那我们的问题在哪
就在messages里
我们写state messages
一旦我输入high或其他内容
就会通过invoke方法传给大语言模型
大语言模型会从云端服务器通过API生成回复
并把结果返回给我们
我们会把它存到response变量里
好了
我们打印一下这个响应
然后返回状态
搞定
当然我们还需要创建图
就像这样
这段代码的意思是
我们创建了一个叫process的节点动作
就是process函数还添加了一条边
从起点到终点
最后编译了图
完美
完成
嗯好的
那么现在让我们请求用户输入user input等于input
我们会说输入点东西
然后我们调用智能体
因为
我们当然需要调用智能体
因为我们正在创建一个图
而这个图就是我们的智能体
对吧
完美
那我们现在运行代码Python agent推bot
好输入hi试试
AI消息
是你好
今天我能帮你做什么
我可以保证这不是预先写死的代码
这是实际的大语言模型
在工作再运行一次
这次换个问题
比如你是谁
他会回答
我是由OpenAI开发的
AI语言模型叫拆778
这基本上可以确认了后台确实是G不
但是为什么只停留在单次对话呢
为什么不支持多伦对话
像聊天机器人那样
所以这里是实现这一点的代码
我来带你看看发生了什么
就像之前一样
我们输入查询
然后通过while循环不断迭代
直到用户输入xx之类的词
这时退出循环表示你不想再和AI大模型对话了
好运行一下Python agent pi
再次输入害它会回应你好
今天怎么样
我们可以继续运行
这只是个简单的while循环
没什么特别的
他回答2+2=4
现在输入
我是鲍勃
好仔细看
我现在要问我刚才说了什么
或者说我的名字是什么
抱歉我无法知道你的名字或任何个人信息
为什么会这样
明明我已经明确说了
快速退出程序
重点来了
代码中没有任何地方实现了记忆功能
这就是为什么我称这一节为简单机器人
这也是为什么我一直说它是AI智能体
但实际上它还算不上真正的智能体
只是一个非常基础的LM封装
不过至少你现在知道
如何将大圆模型集成到图中了对吧
很简单
你只需要把它们嵌入到函数里
函数本身充当动作
就是这样代码非常简单
总共也就25~29行左右
我认为这里不会有练习
因为确实没什么可做的
下一节我们将介绍第二个AI智能体
到时候建
现在我们要构建第二个AI系统
并尝试解决上一个AI系统的问题
问题是什么
问题是我们之前说过的内容
他记不住对吧
为什么
因为我们每次调用的是独立的API
现在我们要尝试创建一个带有某种记忆功能的
聊天机器人
所以我在这里加了个大脑表情符号
让我为大家介绍一下这一小节的目标
我们将使用不同类型的消息
特别是人类消息和AI消息
并用这两种消息类型维护完整的对话历史
我们还将使用GPT复四欧模型
仍然使用LANCHEN的chu pine库
最终我们将创建一个复杂的对话循环
那么这一小节的主要目标是什么
主要是为我们打造一种记忆功能
如果你准备好了
那就进入代码部分吧
好大家加油
开始编写我们的简单聊天机器人
和上次一样
我已经导入了所有必要的库基本相同
只是这次新增了两样东西
AI消息和union类型注解
我在本节开头解释过
为什么我们需要AI消息
而union类型注解
我们在第一章已经讲过了
如果你第一次看到或听到union类型注解
建议回顾第一章
认真理解并观看前两章的内容
说实话它们都很短
然后再回来好了
那我们现在开始编码吧
像往常一样
我们先定义状态
Class agent state typedex
完美上次我们是怎么定义的
还是只有消息
但上次我们用的是人类消息列表
这是我们之前定义的agent state
这次我们也想包含AI消息
毕竟我们在构建一个更复杂的聊天机器人
怎么做呢
一种简单的方式是
直接定义为messages list a message之类的东西
别误会
这种方式虽然简单
但仍然是可行的
这是一种有效的方法
你仍然可以构建你的图和所有相关内容
但我觉得有点啰嗦
所以让我告诉你另一种更好的方法
去掉这个
改用union类型注解
像这样
union像这样
然后我们加上AI消息
这是什么意思呢
让我先简单说一下人类消息和AI消息
人类消息和AI消息以及所有这些不同的结构
实际上是line graph和line嵌中的数据类型
这就是这些库的开发者设计它们的方式
当我写union human message
a message时
这实际上允许我在这个状态件中存储
人类消息或AI消息
这就是messages的意思
简单明了
现在我想提一件重要的事情
所有这些AI智能题库
比如蓝chain land grah
奎瓦OTOON
都很棒
但其实你完全可以通过编写简单的Python函数
来创建自己的AI智能体系统
甚至不需要用到任何库
话虽如此
我还是推荐使用这些库
尤其是land graph
因为这是我个人最喜欢的
完全没有偏见
LANGRAPH真的比其他库让你能控制更多东西
当然没有直接从派森函数自己编写
那么高的控制力
但我认为他在控制力和减少不必要术语
之间达到了很好的平衡
想想看
如果没有蓝GRAFF和蓝茜的支持
你需要写多少不必要的代码
这就是为什么我强烈推荐使用这些库
再次强调
human message和a message是LANGRAPH和LUNCHEN内置的数据类型
好了继续初始化大语言模型
就像上次一样
这次我们仍然只用g p t-4.0
我们要再次创建节点图
结构和之前是一样的
但我们的操作会略有不同
写个文档字符串吧
这个节点将解决你的请求
不过这个小节其实不需要文档字符串
但这是一个好习惯
好的调用它
这里做了什么
这段代码和上一小节完全一样
我们用state messages调用了大语言模型
什么是state messages
它可能是人类消息或AI消息的列表
现在我们写下这段代码
State messages append a message content
等于response content
这到底是什么意思
让我们分解一下
Response content
只是提取响应的内容部分
也就是大语言模型返回的答案或结果
它只提取重要的内容对吧
它去掉了那些不必要的术语
比如使用的词源数量等信息
只保留核心内容
然后将其转换为AI消息
接着这个AI消息被添加到状态中的messages里
为了让终端输出更好看
我们打印一下图
结构和之前完全一样
所以我直接复制粘贴了
毕竟我不想一遍遍在你们面前重写相同的代码
我们可以复用之前的图结构好了
这里是真正开始不同的地方
上次我们没有对话历史记录
而这正是我们这次设置中的记忆功能
我们已经初始化了对话历史记录
接下来我们再次询问用户想要什么
也就是他们的请求
这次我们使用while循环
这个循环和上一小节的完全一样
除非用户输入exit
否则循环不会退出
但现在注意对话历史记录被添加了人类消息
而人类消息显然是用户输入的内容
我之所以写content参数
是因为这是human message的一部分
很好我们调用了智能体
什么是智能体
它是编译后的图
包含了整个对话历史记录
重要的是整个对话历史记录都会被发送
而不仅仅是当前的人类消息
不用担心
我会尽力解释清楚
显然一旦我运行代码
你会更容易理解
如果没完全明白
别担心
暂时删除这部分
然后我们将对话历史记录完全替换为result messages
别担心
等我运行代码后
一切都会清晰起来
我觉得我们现在应该可以运行了
让我们运行Python memory agent pi
这是文件名
我快速输入一个hi
看看API是否工作
完美你好
今天我能帮你做什么
我现在可以说嗨
我叫斯蒂夫
嗨
史蒂夫
很高兴认识你
今天能帮你做什么吗
还记得上次的情况吗
如果我问她
我是谁
她不知道
你觉得现在她会知道吗
想一想
她知道你是斯蒂夫
至少这是你选择告诉我的名字
剩下的部分是肯定的
所以她确实知道我说了什么
但仅仅看这段代码
你可以试着分析它是如何工作的
为什么要这样设计
不过我觉得我们可以添加打印语句
来更好地理解它的运行方式
现在让我们退出程序
添加一个打印语句
这里加一个打印语句
让我把它包含进来
这个打印语句
实际上可以看作是当前状态的一个快照
当它进入处理节点时
在返回状态之前
我们也会打印当前状态
这将直接输出存储在状态中的消息属性
内容好的
清屏重新运行
输入嗨
很高兴认识你
现在看看当前状态
她输出了你好
我也很高兴认识你
我今天能怎么帮你
为什么会输出这个
因为在处理函数中
我们对它进行了格式化
AI的部分是黑AI响应或内容是这一部分
还记得这个响应或内容是如何存储的吗
我们以一种简洁的方式存储
并将其添加到状态的消息列表中
它是被添加到同一个消息列表了吗
是的
你怎么知道的
看人类消息
人类消息是我刚才写的
Hi
很高兴认识你
忽略额外的关键字参数和响应源数据
因为我没有提供任何相关内容
你不需要担心这些重点是这部分内容
再看看AI消息部分
如果内容是你好
很高兴认识你
我今天能怎么帮你注意一下
这和之前的完全一致
现在我们要进一步操作
我会让她说我的名字是斯蒂夫
想一想当前状态会发生什么变化
暂停视频
试着思考一下
好的
我现在发送的第二个消息是我的名字是STEVE
对应的第二个消息是hi steve
今天我能帮你做什么
现在看看当前状态
她仍然从嗨
很高兴认识你开始
这是我在这段对话中输入的第一条消息
接着是AI消息
然后它被添加到状态中
为什么会被添加
因为我们已经添加了AI消息
也添加了人类消息
所以就这样
你可以看到人类消息是我的最新消息
我的名字是STEVE
而AI消息是hi斯蒂夫
今天我能帮你做什么
完美我们可以继续下去
但现在我先退出
事情是这样的
她工作得相对不错
我们成功地得到了一个聊天机器人
这是我们想要的
它有一定的记忆能力
能记住我们是谁
但他有两个大问题
首先是一个巨大的问题
你知道我现在退出了程序
好的
我要再次运行完全相同的程序
我已经告诉他
我的名字是斯蒂夫
我的名字是什么
她说抱歉
我无法访问你的个人数据
再看看当前状态
完全被清空了
原因很明显
因为当你退出程序时
所有变量中的数据都会被清除
状态自然也被清除了
那么解决方案是什么
想一想
显然一个潜在的解决方案是
将数据存储在一个数据库中
比如大型数据库
或者如果你做rag应用
可以使用向量数据库
现在我只是简单地把它存储在一个文本文件中
为什么
因为它非常简单
而且我已经有了代码
老实说
当我做原型开发时
通常就直接用文本文件存储
当然存储在向量数据库或数据库中
更加稳健和复杂
那是你应该做的
但在快速原型开发时
为了快速搭建系统
我倾向于使用文本文件
她仍然能很好地工作
那么文本文件的代码是什么
它在这里
这段代码的意思是
创建一个名为login的文本文件
当然是以写入模式创建的
这个文件会记录你的对话日志
主要是为了让它看起来更整洁
更专业美学
但这是代码中你应该尝试理解的主要部分
对话历史中的每一条消息
好的注意对话历史是这个变量
我们之前初始化了对话历史
它存储了AI消息和人类消息
所以所有图案的信息都在这里对吧
状态被锁定在图内
而对话历史可以说是状态的一个副本
因为我们添加了完全相同的人类消息和AI消息
并不断通过这条线更新
它很好
他的意思是对于对话历史中的每一条消息
顺便说一下
一次对话是从我发送的第一条消息
到我发送的最后一条消息的整个过程
一次对话不仅仅是单次API调用
而是整个长度
好的记住这一点
它首先检查是否是人类消息
如果是就写成你
然后提取内容
如果是AI消息
就归类为AI的部分
让我们再次运行
它先退出清屏
好的
让我们再说
嗨
我是斯蒂夫
我用史蒂夫是因为我的世界电影刚刚上映
所以就这样吧
现在我会故意犯一个拼写错误
God morning
显然morning应该拼写正确
但我这么做是有原因的
没问题
然后说给我讲个笑话
随便来点别的
为什么骷髅不打架
因为他们没有胆量
嗯真是个烂笑话
重点是他能工作
现在我退出程序
它生成了一个conversation safety logtxt文件
来看一下
完美
这是对话日志
我发送的第一条消息是hi
我是斯蒂夫
然后是他的回应
Good morning
为什么我故意拼错了
因为我想展示的是实际的人类消息
我的消息是未经修改存储下来的
无论我在状态中传入什么
人类消息
都会保持原样
AI消息或任何东西都无法改变之前的人类消息
对吧
这就是原因
你可以看到告诉我一个笑话的回应是一个烂
笑话
之后就是login txt文件的结尾
这是一个非常快速高效的方法
当然不是最稳健的方式
但它是一种快速高效的数据存储方式
尤其是当应用停止时完美
那么我提到的第二个问题是什么呢
看这里
一开始我说嗨
我是不知道为什么打印了两次
但无所谓
看看上下文长度
好的
然后我传入另一条消息
它变得更长了
再传入一条消息又变长了
它变得越来越长
这是一个问题
因为想想看
你会使用这些库
这些大语言模型
无论是为了你自己的AI智能体创业公司
你的迷你JAVIS项目
还是其他任何事情
你显然想降低成本对吧
但使用这么多词源
尤其是输入词源
会大幅增加你的花费
这将显著提高成本
这是一个大问题
我们需要稍微保守一点对待我们的钱和财物
那么有什么解决办法呢
想一想
我可以马上给你一个简单的解决方案
在代码中写一些逻辑
比如如果人类消息的数量超过五条
你就从历史记录中删除第一条人类消息
为什么要删除第一条
而不是最新的
因为最新的消息更有可能相关
第一条消息很可能不再需要
或者它有更大的可能性是可以被移除的
内容
它的影响可能较小
为什么我选择五条五只是一个随机数字
你可以选择十十五
二十二十五甚至三都可以
这是一个非常容易实现的解决方案
好的我们学到了很多东西
学会了如何在一个系统中集成
人类消息和AI消息
现在我们已经创建了一个相对复杂的聊天
机器人对吧
它有记忆功能
仍然可以和我们对话
如果我们写下我们是谁
它会记住
并且整体运行得很好
当然它有缺点
但目前来说已经很不错了
接下来我们要构建第三个AI智能体
这是一种特殊类型的智能体
技术术语叫react智能体
react代表推理和行动
这是一种相当常见的AI类型
你将会构建它
它看起来像这样
很简单
有一个起点
然后是终点
接着你有智能体
我们会用一个循环把它连接到工具上
这些工具可以是一个
两个或很多个智能体或背后的大圆模型的任务
不仅是决定选择哪个工具
还要判断什么时候不再需要调用工具
当这种情况发生时
它会进入结束部分
这就是react智能体的基本概念
它是一种在land graph中非常常见
且著名的智能体类型
而这正是我们将在本小节中构建的内容
那么目标是什么呢
构建一个react智能体
的目标是学习如何在land graph中真正创建工具
我们将创建一个react图
当然还会处理不同类型的消息
比如工具消息
看上一小节我们已经涵盖了AI消息和人类消息
但接下来我们将研究更多类型的消息
例如工具消息系统消息
还有基础消息
我们显然要测试图的鲁棒性
主要目标是现在我们要编写入act智能体
提前说一下
这将是一个相当长的小结
做好准备
你可以看到它会很长
因为有很多导入
我已经做了这么多新导入
所以我想花点时间详细解释每一行
这样我们都能理解好的
开始吧
第一行是from typing
import annotated sequence和type dedicate
我们当然知道type dedicate是什么
但我们还没有遇到annotated或sequence
它们也是类型注解
我会先解释什么是annotated
annotated是一种类型注解
它为变量或键提供额外的上下文
而不会影响类型本身的数据类型
这到底是什么意思呢
我给你举个例子
假设我想创建一个type帝dict
里面有一个email键
显然email是字符串类型
如果我要创建一个type dedict
我会写emails对吧
这是我们一直用的方式
但问题是像email这样的键需要符合特定格式
比如必须是a b c g g mail com这种形式
但如果我传入ABCD简dash
减集妙com之类的东西
那就不再是有效的email格式了
但从技术上讲
它仍然是字符串
所以它通过了验证
那么如何解决这个问题呢
这就是annotated的作用
我在这里举个例子
假设email等于annotated
为了节省时间
我不创建整个type地地的
但在示例中
你首先传入你想要的数据类型
我们希望email是字符串对吧
这一点没有改变
但在这里的引号中
我提供了一些额外的信息或上下文
这基本上是在为这个键或变量添加原数据
例如假设这里写必须是有效的email格式
显然我应该更详细地说明
但暂时这样就可以了
那么如何实际查看原数据呢
如果我想查看
我会写print mail metadata
然后运行
好了
你看这里显示必须是有效的email格式
这正是我们在这里写的
这就是annotated的作用
完成了
但是sequence是什么意思呢
sequence也是一种类型注解
我这样描述它
它基本上自动处理这些状态更新
例如向聊天历史记录中添加新消息
这是什么意思呢
它实际上是为了避免对图节点进行
任何列表操作
显然当我们使用图和节点并更新状态时
我们需要做很多列表操作
而sequence可以处理其中的很多内容
这就是它的作用
你不需要太担心它好的继续往下看
我们有EMV
从DOTTONV中导入load dotv
从上一次我们知道
这只是用来存储我们的API密钥的
我在这里加载了API密钥
现在看这三个导入
我们正在导入一些新的消息类型
包括基础消息
工具消息和系统消息
我先从工具消息开始
它本质上是一种消息类型
工具被调用后
数据会传递回大语言模型
传递的信息包括内容本身和工具
调用id工具消息就是这么回事
非常直观
至于系统消息
它是用来向大语言模型提供指令的消息
例如如果你以前用过大语言模型API
你可能写过
You are helpful assistant
这正是系统消息的作用
别担心
我们也会编写这部分代码
你会实际看到它们是什么
那么什么是基础消息呢
在注释中
你可以看到我写到land graph中
所有消息类型的鸡肋
这里是它的工作原理
想想类的层次结构
你知道父类和子类的关系吗
基础消息就是父类
而这些AI消息
人类消息工具
消息系统
消息等其他类型的消息都是子类
它们会继承基础消息的所有属性
因为基础消息是父类
你可以称它为万富之类的东西
但AI消息
人类消息等子类显然会有自己的属性
例如工具消息有自己的内容和工具调用id等
这就是基础消息的作用
它确实是land graph中所有消息类型的鸡肋
很酷好的
现在如果我们继续
继续往下看
我们已经导入了柴头喷奶
完成了状态图
这些我们都遇到过
知道它们是什么
我们还导入了工具和编工具节点
这在课程的第二章或第二节中已经讲过
这些都是我们将在land graph中使用的不同元素
那么这一行呢从line graph graph message中导入id messages
这是什么意思
这个有点不一样
DEMESSAGES是一个reducer函数
如果你是第一次听到这个词
别慌
它并不难
让我复制一下
稍等
reduce函数本质上就是一条规则
控制节点更新如何与现有状态合并
换句话说
它只是告诉我们
如何将新数据合并到当前状态中
问题是
如果我们没有某种
reducer函数更新会完全覆盖现有的值或状态
我给你举个例子
假设我有一个状态
只有一个属性
messages值是害
显然我应该创建一个类型字典并进行规范化
但为了节省时间
我就直接这么写了
现在如果有一个更新说
Nice to meet you
如果没有reducer函数
它会完全覆盖原来的值
在之前的图和智能体中
我们是追加的
但现在我们使用了这么多不同的消息
调用和工具调用
不能总是追加所有内容
那样会变得太复杂
这就是为什么我们需要利用reduce函数
如果不使用reduce函数
它会完全覆盖
但如果使用它
比如hi nice to meet you
他就会追加
这就是关键
简而言之
reduce函数实际上只是聚合状态中的数据
这个reducer函数以及我提到的a AD messages函数
再次强调aid messages是一个reducer函数
它允许我们将所有内容追加到状态中
而不会发生覆盖
因为我们想保留状态
好的很酷
现在让我们实际编写这个react的智能体好了
我已经清屏了
让我们像往常一样开始先定义智能体的状态
像这样定义类型字典
在这个例子中
我们只有一个键
就是messages
现在让我们使用我们学到的新类型注解
sequence space messages和reducer函数
Edit messages
所以这段代码的意思是通过追加
而不是覆盖来保留状态
这就是reducer函数的作用
好的
消息序列是数据类型
这里提供了原数据
这就是为什么我们在这里使用
annotated的关键字
好的
现在让我们
创建我们的第一个工具怎么做呢
一些来自郎茜的同学可能已经知道怎么做了
我们
使用装饰器并这样定义
这个装饰器基本上告诉派森
这个函数很特别
它确实很特别
因为它是
我们要使用的工具
让我们定义工具
为DF创建一个简单的加法工具
我们会说a int b int
它会把两个数字相加
这就是文档字符串的作用
我会展示它的强大之处
现在我们说这是一个加法
函数
它将两个数字相加
好的很简单
我们只需要返回A加B
那么我们如何将这些工具融入大圆模型呢
首先我们创建一个列表
像这样
是的
目前我只有
一个工具
但很快我们会有多个工具
所以我添加了这个列表
现在让我们创建我们的模型
model等于chat opennine
model等于GP-4.0
我使用g p t-4.0
是因为我从未遇到过问题
那么
我们如何告诉g p t-4.0大语言模型
这些是可以使用的工具呢
我们可以使用这个内置的Python函数
Binding tools
像这样使用band tooth
然后传入我们的工具列表
就是tooth
很简单对吧
现在大语言模型可以访问
我们所有的工具了
好的
现在我们需要创建一个节点
作为图中的智能体
怎么做呢
让我创建一个简单的函数
Def model core
传入state
Segent state
它需要返回智能体状态
好的
我快速复制这段代码
稍等
这段代码在做什么
你可以看到我们在调用
模型也就是运行模型
这是我们要求的系统消息
我们明确告诉大语言模型
你是我的助手
请
尽你所能回答我的问题
这就是大语言模型的任务
如果你想更技术化一点
也可以用另一种方式写移除这个
我们可以写system prompt
这里发生了什么
还记得
我说过系统消息也是我们导入的内容之一吗
系统消息就是这行
你是我的助手
请尽你所能回答我的问题
现在无论哪种方式都行得通
如果我直接把这个字符串传入这里
也会起作用
就我个人而言
我认为这种方式更好
尽管他们实现的是完全相同的事情
但我觉得这种方式更好
因为它更具可读性好的
而且你只需要再添加一个导入
所以我更希望你
我真的建议你这样做
这样大语言模型也知道这是一个系统消息
好的很酷
这是更新状态的另一种写法
你知道我们之前写状态的方式是
state messages等于something something something嗯
这也是更新状态的一种更紧凑的方式
所以返回messages response
我们用响应更新messages
而不是用plus equal to这样的写法
或者添加其他东西
我们可以简单地用更新后的状态来写
为什么呢
因为aid messages
也就是reducer函数会帮我们处理追加操作
它不会覆盖
如果我运行这段代码并构建图
一切会正常工作吗
不会为什么不行呢
想想看
当我们调用模型并将响应存储起来时
我们实际上并没有传入查询
我们如何传入查询呢
想想看
我只传入了系统消息
查询放在哪里呢
所以为了能够添加查询
我实际上得这样添加states messages等于query
查询将以人类消息的形式存在
并且人类消息会存储在message属性中对吧
现在我们也把它传入了模型
然后我们就可以调用它了
现在应该可以正常工作了
好的好的
所以现在我们定义条件编
为什么我们这里需要条件编呢
我再把入act智能体的图放这
你可以看到循环部分
就像我们上次在途中第一次创建循环时
你看到那是一个我们必须使用的条件边
现在它实际上会在这里发挥作用
这就是为什么我花了那么多时间构建那些图
因为现在这个概念要用到了
那么我们如何定义条件边呢
第一f should continue
好的和往常一样
我们传入状态就像这样
像这样
否则返回continue
好的
如你所知
你可能已经猜到了
and和continue将是我稍后在图中定义的边
但是这里发生了什么呢
本质上当我传入查询
当我们实际调用模型时
你会知道我们会创建一个工具列表
对吧
所以我们要做的是获取最后一条消息
然后看看是否还需要运行更多工具
如果需要
我们就进入continue边
也就是我们会去到工具节点选择工具
并执行所有操作
而然后回来如果没有更多工具调用了
我们就结束退出图
就是这样
当我们实际测试运行图时
你会更明白我的意思
好的
现在让我们定义图和往常一样
我们创建图
通过state graph初始化图
然后把节点命名为ARRANGENT
那么动作就是model call
也就是底层函数会是这个好的
现在我们创建一个叫做工具节点的东西
这也是我们在课程的第二章或第二节中
讲过的内容
工具节点本质上就是一个单独的节点
它包含所有不同的工具
如果你看这个变量tools
我们现在只有一个工具
就是AD
别担心我们稍后会添加更多工具
比如减法和乘法
但我只是想真正巩固一下
你对我们如何添加这些工具
以及图如何工作的概念
好的现在我们显然要设置入口点
并将其指向arr agent
现在让我们添加条件边
还记得我之前说过有两条边continue和end吗
再强调一下continue和end
如果它指向and我们就结束
如果它指向tooth
我们就去到工具节点
也就是tooth
好的好的
所以这仍然很简单对吧
现在我们还需要添加一条
从我们的工具回到智能体的边
因为这就是我们创建循环连接的方式对吧
你可以看到条件边只提供了一个单向的有向边
从智能体到工具节点
或者从智能体到终点
但我们需要另一条边从工具节点回到智能体
这就是这条边的作用
最后我们显然要编译它
所以我们就说APP等于graph compile
完美就是这样
现在我在这里创建了一个新的辅助函数
这不是land graph的一部分
我只是写了这段代码
因为它会让每个工具调用等操作
以更好的方式输出
你马上就会明白我的意思
好的
现在我们实际上可以开始了
比如说输入是这样的
假设我想计算3+4很简单
这行代码基本上会进行流式处理
比如我想要加3+4简单
从工具节点回到智能体
这就是这条边的作用
最后我们显然要编译它
所以我们就说APP等于graph compile
完美就是这样
现在我在这里创建了一个新的辅助函数
这不是land graph的一部分
我只是写了这段代码
因为它会让每个工具调用等操作
以更好的方式输出
你马上就会明白我的意思
好的
现在我们实际上可以开始了
比如说输入是这样的
假设我想计算3+4很简单
这行代码基本上会进行流式处理
比如说输入是这样的
假设我想计算3+4很简单
这行代码基本上会进行流式处理
比如说输入是这样的
假设我想计算3+4很简单
这行代码基本上会进行流式处理
这就是它的全部功能
那么让我们运行一下清屏
然后开始吧
还记得我们写了AD three plus four吗
哇看看这个我们成功地加了3+4
它调用了工具
甚至知道要选择哪个工具ADD
并给出了结果
正如你所看到的工具消息是七
而最终的AI消息是三和四的合适期
就是这么简单
现在让我们尝试一些更难的东西
比如试着加34+21
如果我们运行这个
你可以看到结果是55
因为34+21=55
而且你还可以再次看到所有的工具
调用和操作步骤
我想再展示两件事
然后再添加更多工具
如果我现在移除这里的文档字符串
暂时注释掉
清屏
再运行一下
看报错了
为什么
因为如果没有提供描述函数
必须有文档字符串
文档字符串是必要的
所以一定要包括它
否则图不会工作
记住他告诉大圆模型这个工具是用来干什么的
好的
既然我们已经解决了这个问题
让我们再试试这个AD three plus four
这次我希望他们都被执行清平
你认为这会起作用吗
让我们看看
34+21和3+4完美太棒了
你可以看到34+21的结果是55
3+4的结果是七
你可以看到这次工具被调用了两次
这就是我们创建的循环的力量
还记得我们创建了条件编
然后还创建了从工具节点返回智能体的
有向边吗
让我们再试一下稍微复杂一点的内容
比如说ADDAD1212这样的东西
让我清屏看看会发生什么
哇看看这个
如果我按下回车
抱歉我搞错了该死
但你也可以看到额外的结果
34+21=55
7+24=31
你还可以看到我调用了工具三次
这两次调用也表明了
大语言模型没有使用它训练时学到的内置信息
来得出答案
对吧
记住大语言模型不知道如何做数学题
它只是通过概率猜测下一个输出
但通过这种方式
我们实际上能够正确地将两个数字相加
这里的一个重要概念是
大语言模型实际上决定应该将哪些参数
传递给每个工具
例如如果我说AD three plus four
它实际上会
创建输入数字三和四
并由这个工具处理信息
返回结果
然后返回到智能体
AI智能体会决定最终的答案是什么
就是这样运作的太棒了
好的
现在让我们让它变得更复杂一些
添加更多工具
比如subtract和multiply
唯一需要做的更改是
除了这一行
我们现在也包括subtract和multiply
就这样
其他代码基本保持不变
现在让我们实际运行一下
看看她是否会因为不同的工具而感到困惑
让我们看看好的
你可以再次看到
五十五七百二十四
它没有混淆完美
现在让我们给他一个不同的命令
比如说这样稍等一下
a d d 40+12
然后将结果乘以六
现在他必须使用两种不同的工具
让我们看看它会不会卡住
好的哇
太棒了
他首先使用了ADD工具
然后使用了multiply工具
你可以看到所有的查询工具调用和操作步骤
最终答案是312
52×6
是的等于312哇
这运行得非常出色
现在我们知道这个系统很稳健了
那么如果我再添加这个呢
请告诉我一个笑话
你觉得会发生什么
你认为这会崩溃吗
让我们看看运行一下
让我们看看
哇看看这个40+12=52
52×6=312
这是给你的笑话
为什么骷髅不打架
因为他们没有枪
天哪总是这个老掉牙的笑话
但你明白我的意思了
这个系统如此稳健
即使在不需要工具的情况下也能处理问题
女士们
先生们
这就是land graph的强大之处
即使我们不需要使用工具
它仍然能给我们答案
它之所以能做到这一点
是因为所有工具调用完成后
传回给智能体
智能体会再次检查哦
我还需要告诉用户一个笑话
并将笑话添加到最终信息中
然后结束
这就是land graph的力量
好了
在这一切之后
我们终于学会了如何创建一个react智能体
是的
这是一个简单的react智能体
但它已经展示了联GRAFF的能力
但概念是一样的
从现在起
你可以创建自己的外部工具
也可以创建自己的图
这就是本课程的重点
就是让你真正理解如何创建这些工具
以及如何使用不同的工具
剩下的就取决于你了
全凭你的想象力
好的完美
那么我们下一小节再见
好的
到时候见好了
大家到目前为止
我们已经取得了很大的进展
做得很好
但现在我们要创建第四个AI智能体
这次我们的做法会稍有不同
这次我们要一起做一个小项目
这个项目的名字叫作起草助手
一会儿你就会明白为什么叫这个名字
想象一下
我和你在一家公司共事
我们的老板来找我们
他有一个问题
还给了我们一些任务
问题是这样的
我们公司的工作效率不高
我们在起草文件上花费了太多时间
这个问题需要解决
这是个很实际的问题
它给我们的任务是什么呢
他说你们需要创建一个AI智能体系统
能够加快起草文件
电子邮件等的速度
这个AI智能体系统应该具备人机协作功能
也就是说人类应该能够提供持续的反馈
并且当人类对草稿满意时
AI智能体应该停止
这个系统还应该运行快速
并且能够保存草稿
好的
然后我和你开始讨论
我们显然要使用蓝GRAFF
然后我们想出了一个草图
我们图的草图大概是这样的
它显然会有一个起点和一个终点
还会有我们的智能体
智能体可以访问工具
也就是工具节点
这看起来和我们上一小节讲的
react智能体有点相似
但有一个原因我们没有选择那样做
你看我们意识到其中一个工具是保存工具
它会保存草稿
这是我们的需求之一
但显然一旦我们保存了草稿
这个过程就应该结束对吧
但如果你还记得
react智能体工具总是会回到AI智能体
而不是直接到终点
我们不想这样了
所以这就是为什么一旦使用了保存工具
因为保存工具会
在工具里面它就结束了
这就是我们选择的结构
所以剩下的唯一事情就是实际编写这个图了
那我们一起开始吧
好的
那我们实际编写这个起草助手项目
你可以看到我已经完成了所有的导入
并且加载了
我的环境文件
现在所有这些导入都是我们之前已经遇到过的
所以再看它们也没什么意义
但我要做的第一件事是定义全局变量
现在定义全局变量有点奇怪
我这么做是有原因的
随着我讲解代码
这个原因会变得更明显
但先提前说一下
我在这种情况下定义全局变量的原因是为了
在工具中传递状态
在LANGRAPH中
正确的做法是通过一种叫做注入状态的方式
但注入状态超出了本课程的范围
所以一个变通方法是使用全局变量
会发生的情况
是我们的工具所做的任何更新
都会更新全局变量
然后
当我们继续保存时
保存工具会使用这个全局变量中的内容
并将其保存到一个文本文件中
所以这就是为什么要包含它
好的
现在让我们再次定义智能体状态
做法和我们上次完全一样
Class agent state messages annotated sequence
Space messages
Add messages as the reducer function
所以现在我们定义工具
这个项目会有两个工具
第一个工具是更新工具
第二个工具是保存工具
让我们从更新工具开始
我显然会使用装饰器
然后创建def update
如果我们需要传入一个参数content
现在回顾一下
无论你传入什么参数或者请求什么参数
实际上是谁得到这些参数呢
是大语言模型或者后台的东西
它会自动为这个工具的这个模型传递参数
所以在这种情况下
content参数将由后台的大语言模型提供
所以你不用担心这个好的
现在我们显然需要文档字符串
我刚刚创建了一个简单的文档字符串
他用提供的内容更新文档
因为这正是他要做的
所以现在我们定义在拍摄中与全局变量交互
你显然需要
定义它
你需要这样调用它
然后你需要用当前内容更新你的文档内容
也就是全局变量
然后你只需要再次返回一个语句给大语言模型
告诉他我们已经成功更新了
所以我写了文档已成功更新
当前内容是这个
这就是我们存储在里面的内容
好的
现在我们定义第二个工具
也就是保存工具
同样的装饰器
我们需要传入一个参数content
现在回顾一下
无论你传入什么参数或者请求什么参数
实际上是谁得到这些参数呢
是大语言模型或者后台的东西
它会自动为这个工具的这个模型传递参数
所以在这种情况下
content参数将由后台的大语言模型提供
所以你不用担心这个好的
现在我们显然需要文档字符串
我刚刚创建了一个简单的文档字符串
它用提供的内容更新文档
因为这正是他要做的使用
像这样
现在我们还要求大语言模型给我们一个文件名
这样它应该会给我们一个合适的文件名
这个文件名
会是适合文本文件的文件名
最终这个保存工具会自动处理所有的保存逻辑
所以作为文档字符串
我这样写
将当前文档保存到文本文件并结束流程
参数是file name
这是文本文件的文件名
我特意提到我们将使用文本文件
这样
大圆模型就知道它需要传递的文件名
末尾必须有TXT
现在如果出于任何原因
为了让图和整个代码更健壮
我还写了这个if语句
这样如果这个文件名末尾没有TXT
就在后面加上TXT
这只是一种健壮性措施
现在我们又需要调用全局变量了
Global document content
现在接下来这部分
代码
这不是language相关的
这只是你在工具中放入的内容
它不一定与language相关对吧
所以这部分
代码只是一些
能让你将保存在全局变量中的内容
以文本文件的形式
在指定文件名之下保存的代码
我还添加了这个异常处理
这对调试很有帮助
如果有错误
他会准确告诉我是什么
错误
然后我们就可以修复它
好的
希望不会有任何错误
现在我们创建一个工具列表
这个列表里又会有updates
和save
因为我们只有这两个工具
现在我们实际调用模型
我们该如何调用模型呢
就像这样
现在我问你一个
问题这样定义模型够吗
还是我们还需要别的东西
我问这个问题是有原因的
我们忘了绑定工具
所以
Btooth tooth tooth
这样就可以了
现在我们实际初始化智能体本身
或者说初始化这个函数
因为记住智能体将是我们图中的一个节点
而在它背后的函数
就是我们即将定义的这个函数
所以我们这样写DEFAULAGENT同样
我们需要传入状态
也就是智能体状态
并且它将返回智能体状态
好的现在在这个过程中
我们需要
向我们的大预言模型传入一个系统消息
这个系统提示会比较长
做好准备
像这样
在这个系统提示中
我特别说明
这是一个系统消息
内容是你是起草助手
一个很有帮助的写作助手
你将帮助用户
也就是我们更新和修改文档
我还写了一些其他内容
关于如果用户想要更新文档
我们该怎么做
我们使用更新工具
如果要保存文档
我们需要使用保存工具
并且在修改后
总是展示当前文档等等之类的内容
好了没问题
现在是时候进行一些深入讨论了
当我们第一次初始化图的时候
比如当我们写第一条消息时
显然我们不会直接问你想如何更改文档
因为我们还没有传入文档
所以
如果messages为空
这部分如果state messages里什么都没有
我们就得说一些类似介绍性的消息对吧
这就是你可以这样做的方法
我们可以说如果state messages为空
也就是如果state messages里什么都没有
那么我们可以说我准备好帮助你更新文档了
你想创建什么文档
然后它收集用户输入
并将其作为人类消息存储在user message变量中
现在如果我已经传入了一条消息
或者我们正在更新草稿或起草文档的过程中
要做到这一点
我们需要这个else语句
他是怎么说的呢
他说你想对文档做什么
所以假设这意味着state messages里已经有内容了
在状态中你想如何进一步更新它
然后我们还会在终端上
这个表情符号下面打印出来
这样用户也能看到他们输入了什么
然后这也会存储在user message中
好的
现在我们将所有这些消息
也就是系统提示
即系统消息组合起来
我们创建一个列表
这个列表包含state messages和user message
也就是我们想要的新消息
也就是更新消息
然后我们调用模型
我们如何调用模型呢
你只需要
使用model invoke好的
到目前为止代码很基础
没有什么难的
也没有什么
特别的或者是我们没见过的
我们之前都见过这些内容
现在这个函数的其余部分只是一个打印语句
我添加这个打印语句
只是为了让终端上的内容看起来更美观
仅此而已
你可以看到这些部分会打印出AI的回复
然后还会打印出工具相关的内容
不管这两条消息是什么
这就是目的
这里没有什么特别需要讨论的
然后我们显然还需要
返回更新后的状态
记住上次我给你展示过
这也是更新状态非常方便简洁的方法
所以从现在起
我们只会用这种方式返回更新后的状态
记住上次我给你展示过
这也是更新状态非常方便简洁的方法
所以从现在起
我们只会用这种方式
像这样更新状态
现在我们来创建条件边函数
也就是条件边背后的函数
还记得吧
我打开这个图给你们看
我说的条件边就是这个从工具节点出来
有两种选择
要么回到智能体
要么结束流程
所以我们要创建这个背后的底层函数
现在就来创建
should的continue
我们之前做过很多次了
他会判断我们是否要继续对话
记住是继续还是结束对话
这完全说得通
我说的这个条件边就是从工具节点这里出来的
这条从工具节点出来后
有两种选择
要么回到智能体
要么结束流程
所以我们现在来创建它背后的底层函数
Should continue
这个我们之前搞过好多次了
它能决定我们是接着对话还是结束对话
这很好理解
我们这么做是为了判断对话是继续还是结束
这很合理
现在开始处理
我们先获取消息
如果消息为空
显然要继续
不会直接到结束环节
说实话
这只是为了让逻辑更严谨
我们获取消息
如果消息为空
那显然得继续
不会直接到结束部分
说实话
这就是保证逻辑严谨
这段代码的意思是看看最近使用的工具消息
或者说最近用的工具
我们要检查这个工具是不是保存工具
为啥呢
我们有两个工具
一个是更新工具
一个是保存工具
我们有更新工具和保存工具
这两个工具如果用的是更新工具
那肯定得走继续分支
但如果用的是保存工具
保存完了就没别的事了
草稿完成
所有事都结束了
那就可以结束程序了
这就是结束工具的意义
如果用更新工具就走
继续编
用保存工具就走
结束编应该能理解了吧
要是不理解也别担心
我们会多打一些信息
让你看清工作流程
要走继续编就得用更新工具
要走结束边就得用保存工具
现在应该明白了吧
要是不明白也别担心
我们会多打印些语句
让你看清工作流程
要是还不明白
也别担心
我们会多打印些内容
让你看清工作流程
最后默认情况下
如果没用到保存工具
那用的就是更新工具
就得走
继续编这个函数就完成了
挺简单的
最后我们显然要返回continue
因为这里默认检查是否用了保存工具
剩下的就只有更新工具
更新工具意味着要走
继续编
这个函数也完成了
挺简单的
接下来这个函数我写
它只是为了让打印的消息在终端上格式更易读
它只是为了让打印的语句在终端上格式更易读
等我们实际运行图查看处理流程时
你就知道它的用处了
现在我们来创建图
创建图的方法
我们已经用过很多次了
通过STAGRAPH来初始化
然后添加节点
有智能体节点和工具节点
工具节点是个特殊节点
要是你留意之前的图有两个节点
智能体节点和工具节点
我在图和代码之间来回对照
就是为了让你清楚我们在编码的内容
现在我们来创建图
我们多次用过这种方法
通过状态图初始化
然后添加节点
有智能体节点和工具节点
工具节点就是那种节点
要是你回看之前的图有两个节点
智能体节点和工具节点
我在图和代码之间来回对照
就是为了让你清楚我们在编码的内容
我们添加了智能体节点和工具节点
现在把入口点设为智能体
也就是起点
我们已经添加了智能体节点和工具节点
现在把入口点设为智能体
也就是起点
然后在智能体和工具节点之间添加一条边
显然得创建这条边
因为智能体要调用工具
我们得创建这条边
这条有向边和条件边构成循环
能实现人机协作
现在添加条件编
就是我之前说的那个决定继续还是结束的
条件编
从工具节点出来的这条
现在添加条件边
就是我之前说的那个决定继续还是结束的
条件边
从工具节点这里出来的这条
最后我们要做的就是编译图
图已经完全创建好了
起点终点条件边节点有相边都弄好了
起点也确定了
这样整个图就创建好了也不难
最后我们要做的就是编译图
因为图已经完全创建好了
起点终点条件边节点有向边都搞定了
起点也弄好了
你能看到整个图就这么创建好了也不难
起点终点条件边节点有向边都完成了
起点也确定好了
你能看到整个图就这么创建好了
挺简单的
整个图就这么创建好了也不难
现在我们来运行程序
我写了个函数
让运行更简洁
就是为了调用图
我们来运行一下
这就是完整代码了
这段代码能实现人机协作
没错我们用了全局变量
用全局变量也没什么错
我知道有些人可能不喜欢
但如果要用land graph里更复杂的东西
比如注入状态或者用命令和中断代码
就得稍微改动一下
但这是入门课程
我们就先不管那些
找到了另一种实现人机协作的方法
现在我们来运行程序
我写的这个函数让运行更简洁
就是为了调用图
这就是全部代码了
这段代码能实现人机协作
确实我们用了全局变量
用全局变量也没错
我知道有些人可能不喜欢
但要是用LANGUGRAPH里更复杂的功能
像注入状态或者用命令和中断代码就得改改
但这是入门课程
我们就不考虑
那些找到了另一种实现人机协作的方法
确实用了全局变量
用全局变量也没毛病
我知道有些人可能不太喜欢
但如果要用LANGUGRAPH里更复杂的内容
比如注入状态或者使用命令和中断代码
就得稍微改改
但这是入门课程
我们就先不管那些找到了另一种
实现人机协作的办法
如果我们想用land graph里更复杂的东西
比如注入状态或者使用命令和中断代码
就得稍微不同
但因为这是入门课程
我们就完全不考虑那些找到了另一种
实现人机协作的方法
因为这是入门课程
我们就先不考虑那些找到了另一种
实现人机协作的方法
太棒了
现在来运行一下
输入pia draft
Pia
我把界面调小一点
希望你能看清所有内容
现在提示你文档为空
问你要添加或创建什么内容
太棒了
现在来运行一下
输入Python draft
派
我把界面调小一点
希望你能看清所有内容
现在提示你文档为空
问你要在文档里添加或创建什么
比如说我们要给同事汤姆写封邮件
说我们不能参加会议
现在文档为空
问你想在文档里添加或创建什么
比如说我们要给同事汤姆写封邮件
说我们不能参加会议
说我们没法参加会议
比如说输入write me an email to tom
Saying
I cannot make it to the meeting
看看他怎么说
看看他怎么回复他
回复hi tom
I hope this has found you
Well
现在我们来给点反馈
说说怎么改进
你还可以看到它也使用了更新工具完美
比如说确保指定会议原本应该
在上午十点
在某个随机的度假胜地
加纳利郎
好的
我们来看看更新后的内容
hi汤姆
你可以看到消息说会议是上午十点
由于不可预见的情况
我无法参加
我不太喜欢这部分提到的名字
所以让我们改一下
比如我的名字是
它会更新这个内容
你看非常完美
接下来还有什么要修改的吗
我们还可以说一些类似这样的话
比如蛋
告诉她我可以在中午12点参加会议
在纽约某个随机地点好吧
这是我编的
但你应该明白我的意思
第二天
所以我们来看一下
不过我可以在第二天中午12点在纽约见面
显然这封邮件
写得很随意
时间地点都不严谨
但你可以看到我们在这里实现了人机协作
还有一点我不太喜欢的是
这部分没有换行
我是有点挑剔
但我们可以这样要求
把这条信息调整得更好一点
太棒了
正如你所见
这也完成了
现在假设我说我喜欢它
请保存
会发生什么呢
你可以看到它使用了
保存工具工具的结果是文档已成功更新
当前内容如下
文档已保存为无法参加会议的邮件
记住我们从未传入文件名
这完全是智能体自己生成的
为了确认我们需要去查看无法参加会议的文件
我们来看一下
就是这个
你可以看到这就是我们刚才写的邮件主题
问候语签名
所有内容都一模一样完美
而且我们不
仅限于起草邮件
我们甚至可以起草短篇故事
或者任何我们想要的内容
事实上我们还可以传入
之前的消息之所以它是从空白开始的
是因为我们传入了一个空列表
但如果我们想的话
我们也可以在这里
写一些现有的邮件或现有文档内容
然后模型和智能体系统就会知道
这是当前的内容
并询问你如何修改它
这正是我们能够操作现有内容的方式
你可以看到
这是一个相当健壮的系统
如果需要另一个例子
比如运行派送派
好的再看这个
看看他的健壮性
如果我说写一封邮件
它实际上会提出问题
比如当然你想让邮件说什么
记住这里完全没有经过任何工具使用land graph
我们可以让智能体变得非常强大
而这正是我想展示给你们的智能体
并不总是必须选择工具
也不一定完全依赖大语言模型本身
因为记住智能体节点背后有一个大语言模型
作为后端支持
巴恩兔子函数扩展了他的能力范围
通过提供一些工具增强了它的功能
但这并不意味着它必须使用这些工具
如果他觉得不需要用工具
他就不会用
在这种情况下
她想向我们提出更多问题
于是他问我们希望这封邮件写什么
说实话我只写了三个词
但这正是我想展示给你们的
好了
现在让我们清空这个
因为我们不需要了
是的
你可以看到人机协作在land graph中完美运作
并且这确实有一些实际用途
当然
你可以使用g p t-4.0
canvas和其他那些工具
但这就是你如何在line graph中实现它的方式好了
如果你想要对此进行扩展
你可以添加语音功能
也许你可以使用open night的whisper
进行语音到文本的转换
或者
添加11lips进行文本到语音的转换
甚至可以制作一个语音界面
因为目前我是通过文本模式与它交互的
如果是语音模式呢
你还可以为此添加图形用户界面
GOE还有很多可以做的事情
你甚至可以有自己的知识库
并将它包含进去
这个项目有很大的潜力
如果你想为这个特定项目做作业
那就去做吧
好了太酷了
这就是本小节的结尾
太棒了
现在让我们来构建第五个AI智能体
有些人可能已经期待这个了
那就是检索增强生成软克
那么图会是什么样子
它看起来像这样
起点终点非常类似于react智能体对吧
但是在这种情况里
我们有两个智能体
一个是检索器智能体
另一个是我们主要的大语言模型智能体
并且它显然会有条件边和循环
我们要把目前学到的所有内容整合起来
融为一体
而且我们还会稍微了解一下rag
我假定你们知道rag是什么
就不深入讲解其细节了
不过我会在表面层面解释一下
rag是关于什么的
以及相关的所有内容
好的要是你很感兴趣
那我们就直接看代码
现在你可以看到
我已经完成了所有需要的导入操作
不过你会注意到有四个导入我们之前没见过
与其一开始就解释它们
我会在用到的时候再解释
因为这样更有意义
也更直观
好的
现在我要加载
包含所有AAPI密钥的involve文件
这次我初始化大语言模型的方式略有不同
其实还是同一个大语言模型
但为什么说不同呢
因为我传入了一个新参数
temperature温度
对于不知道温度是什么的人来说
它本质上是一个参数
它描述了模型输出的随机性
也就是你希望模型输出有多随机
因为我把它设为零
temperature等于零
会让模型输出更具确定性
类似的
如果我把温度设为一
模型输出就会更随机
好的
现在我们创建嵌入模型
嵌入模型会把我们的文本转换成向量嵌入对吧
这就是他的工作方式
现在请注意一件重要的事情
就是
嵌入模型
必须与我们正在使用的大语言模型兼容
你可以使用任何你想要的大语言模型
但要确保嵌入模型与它兼容
例如假设我们使用的是OpenAI模型
但我们用的嵌入模型
来自欧拉A或其它随机模型
那么很可能它们不兼容
为什么呢
因为它们之间有很多差异
一个潜在的差异可能是向量维度
所以一般来说要确保大语言模型和嵌入模型
兼容好的
现在我们要指定PDF部分
这是2024年股票市场表现的PDF文件
实际上这是我创建的一个文档
里面包含了很多关于股票市场表现的内容
我现在就可以给你展示
这个文档
有九页
就是一个包含2024年
一些股票市场细节的文档
好的太棒了
现在如果你的PDF文件目录放错了
或者程序找不到它
就会弹出这个错误
我家这个只是为了调试目的
如果你用我在GITHUB上提供的代码
现在这个会加载PDF文件
你可以看到p PDF loader是我们在这里导入的
其中一个
它就在名字里很常见
就是简单的加载PDF文件
好的
这个try and accept命令会检查PDF文件是否存在
pages等于Pdf loader loader
这基本上是在说文档里有多少页
你可以看到我们的文档有九页
所以如果我运行这个命令
运行Python regent拍
它应该会显示九页没错
PDF文件已加载
正如预期有九页
好的
现在到了分块过程
什么是分块呢
首先看这里
我指定了两个参数
将塞子块大小是1000
枪控overlap快
重叠是200
让我们详细解释一下
回到文档
枪size是1000个词源
比如说这是一个快
例如显然这不是真正的词源
但为了掩饰目的
我们假设它是一旦达到1000个词源
你就创建一个新快
比如说1000个词源在这里结束
那么这就是一个新快的开始
像这样
然后你继续往后直到文档结尾
但是第二个参数chunk overlap呢
它的意思是让我用不同颜色表示连续的快
应该有一些共同的词源
例如因为是200
第二个块不会从这里开始
实际上会从类似这样的地方开始
它们在词源数量上显然是一样长的
但会有一些词源同时存在于两个块中
例如这部分会同时在两个块中
准确的说是200个词源的重叠部分
所以这就是rag中块的简要概述好了
这部分完成了recursive correct text platter
是我们导入的其中一个
现在我们将这个文本分块过程
应用到文档的所有页面
这段代码基本上是说
我们要使用CHROMA向量数据库来存储
所有的向量嵌入
顺便说一下
我们希望CHROMA向量数据库所在的位置
将在这个文件部分指定
然后集合名称将被称为股票市场
你可以随意指定位置
显然但我只是指定它在同一个文件夹里
所以这只是一个EIF语句
以确保如果这是我们第一次运行这个命令
如果我们运行这个文件
如果这个集合不存在
如果这是我们第一次运行这个命令
如果我们运行这个文件
如果这个集合不存在
我们要把目前学到所有东西都整合起来
融为一体
而且我们还会稍微了解一下瑞克
我假定你们知道rag是什么
就不深入讲他的细节了
不过我会在表面层面解释一下
rag是关于什么的
以及相关所有内容
好的
要是你很感兴趣
那我们就直接看代码
现在你可以看到
我已经完成了所有需要的导入操作
不过你会注意到有四个导入我们之前没见过
与其一开始就解释它们
我会在用到的时候再解释
因为这样更有意义
也更直观
好的
现在我要加载包含所有AAPI密钥的INBEV文件
这次我初始化大语言模型的方式略有不同
其实还是同一个大语言模型
但为什么说不同呢
因为我传入了一个新参数
Temperature
温度对于不知道温度是什么的人来说
它本质上是一个参数
它描述了模型输出的随机性
也就是你希望模型输出有多随机
因为我把它设为零
temperature等于零
会让模型输出更具确定性
类似的
如果我把温度设为一模型输出就会更随机
好的
现在我们创建嵌入模型
嵌入模型会把我们的文本转换成向量嵌入对吧
这就是它的工作方式
现在请注意一件重要的事情
就是嵌入模型
必须与我们正在使用的大语言模型兼容
你可以使用任何你想要的大语言模型
但要确保嵌入模型与它兼容
例如假设我们使用的是OpenAI模型
但我们用的嵌入模型
来自欧拉马或其它随机模型
那么很可能它们不兼容
为什么呢
因为它们之间有很多差异
一个潜在的差异可能是向量维度
所以一般来说要确保大圆模型和嵌入模型兼容
好的
现在我们要指定PDF部分
这是2024年股票市场表现的PDF文件
实际上这是我创建的一个文档
里面包含了很多关于股票市场表现的内容
我现在就可以给你展示
这个文档
有九页
就是一个包含2024年
一些股票市场细节的文档
好的太棒了
现在如果你的PDF文件目录放错了
或者程序找不到
它
就会弹出这个错误
我加这个只是为了调试目的
如果你用我在GITHUB上提供的代码
现在这个会加载PDF文件
你可以看到p PDF loader是我们在这里导入的
其中一个
它就在名字里很常见
就是简单的加载PDF文件
好的
这个try and accept命令会检查PDF文件是否存在
pages等于Pdf loader loader
这基本上是在说文档里有多少页
你可以看到我们的文档有九页
所以如果我运行这个命令
运行Python regent
它应该会显示九页没错
PDF文件已加载
正如预期有九页
好的
现在到了分块过程
如果不存在
我们将在指定目录中创建集合
好的再次说明这并不难
现在是一个try检except命令块
也就是try检except块
这里是我们实际创建向量嵌入的地方
也就是创建CHROMA向量数据库的地方
这些只是指定的参数
例如我希望页面如何分割
使用哪种嵌入存储在哪里
以及集合名称
集合名称是股票市场对吧
如果有错误
它会抛出错误
如果成功
他会在终端打印出来
好的太棒了
现在我们来创建一个叫retriever的东西
retriever在rag中非常重要
它是检索增强生成
retrial augmented generation的第一部分
retriever实际上是负责检索最相似快的部分
我们使用的搜索方法是similarity相似性
这是默认设置
说实话你不需要了解它的具体原理
但你需要知道的是
这部分内容
在这段代码中
我确保每次返回的快数量是五个
为什么呢
因为这里的K就是返回的快数量
我将其设置为五
我很确定
如果我们查看实际文档
默认值是四
所以这是一个你可以调整的参数
当然你不希望它太高或太低
而是要找到一个合适的中间值
并在我看来
四或五是一个不错的中间值
好的
现在让我们创建我们的工具
我们再次使用涂装饰器
这个工具的名字将是retriever to
它会接受一个查询
并输出一个字符串
文档字符串如下
这个工具会搜索并返回文档中的信息
非常直观
显然我们需要调用它给retriever
不管我们问什么问题
比如苹果公司在2024年的表现如何
这个问题会被传递给retriever
他会抓取最相似的前五个块
好的如果我们没有找到任何相似的内容
例如我说谁是bob the builder
显然bob的builder不在这个文档中
所以它会返回我在文档中未找到相关信息
然后
这将被传递给我们的大语言模型智能体
如果找到了相关内容
我们会做的是创建一个空列表
并
存储所有找到的相似块
然后通过这段代码返回
结果仍然很简单
这段代码我们已经见过只有一个工具
所以我们只需将该工具
绑定到我们的大语言模型上
这段代码我们也做过很多次了
它是创建智能体状态
我们再次使用AD messages简化函数
所有这些我们都讲过很多次了
你应该已经很熟悉了
好的现在我们创建
书多continue函数
书多continue函数将成为条件边背后的底层函数
它会检查最后一条消息是否包含任何工具调用
如果包含我们就继续
如果不包含就结束
好的
现在我们指定系统提示词
这个系统提示词会比较大
让我把它复制粘贴到这里
之所以这么大
是因为我想尽可能多地提供信息
以便她知道该做什么
我只是说你是一个智能AI助手
可以回答关于加载到知识库中的文档的问题
如果你想的话
可以阅读其余部分
我还写了
请始终引用你在答案中使用的文档的具体部分
这主要是为了确保它不会产生幻觉
因为我们知道幻觉是大语言模型的一个大问题
这只是为了确保幻觉降到最低
好的现在我们创建工具的字典
接下来我们创建底层函数
也就是我们的大语言模型智能体
这个函数会调用大语言模型和当前状态
你可以看到它将消息转换为列表
传递系统消息
并将其传递给我们的大语言模型
它就像这样定义并返回消息
也就是更新后的状态应该像这样
太棒了
现在我们创建第二个智能体
也就是我们在图中看到的retriever智能体
retriever智能体
会从大语言模型响应中执行两次调用
那么这段代码到底是什么意思呢
归根结底
这段庞大的代码实际上只是说
如果有一个工具
并且工具名称是一个正确指定的工具
比如retriever to
那么它就会执行相关操作
好的
这就是整个逻辑
如果工具名称是retriever to
那就没问题
然后实际运行它如果不是
我们会输出结果为工具名称错误
请重试
并从可用工具列表中选择工具
这只是为了检查大语言模型决定的工具
是否有效
如果有效
它将调用该工具
我们将以这种方式存储结果并返回它
这应该像刚才那样的智能体状态好的
我们已经创建了两个AI智能体
现在我们要创建图表本身
就像我们之前通过state graph初始化一样
然后我们将把两个AI智能体作为节点
并添加它们各自的动作
我们现在要添加条件编
这个条件编将从大语言模型开始
输入的continue函数是底层函数
这是一个布尔语句
这是入口点的边
所有这些我们都讲过很多次了
所以你应该相当熟悉了
最后但同样重要的是编译图表
并将其存储在我们的rage智能体中
还有一件事
我创建了这个函数
这个函数只是一个允许我们不断向图表提问
并接收答案的函数
如果你想退出
可以输入exit或quit
这只是一个简单的while循环
仅此而已
它会打印出答案
这就是完整的代码
现在我们要测试一下
看看它是否可靠
好的让我们来实际测试一下
执行Python reagent派
让我们运行一下PDF
已加载
由九页创建了库罗马向量数据库和向量存储库
那么它存储在哪里呢
你可以看到
顺便说一下
这个也会在GITHUB上
这是CHROMA数据库及其相应的bin文件夹
我们可以查看它
不过看起来就像这样
因为它已经成功创建了
这是个好迹象
说明一切都正常工作
让我们问一个简单的问题
比如塞批500在2024年的表现如何
回车
他正在使用查询
调用retriever工具
这是它的结果
并且完整返回给了模型
模型给出了以下答案
在2024年
CP500的总回报率为某个值
增长了23%
1990年代末
2000年代初的那些热门七大股票等等
并给出了相应的引用
我们如何验证这是正确的呢
让我来看一下
注意如果你记得这部分内容
大约25%的总回报率
我之所以问这个问题
是因为那正是这里所写的
基准大约是25%
23%左右
记住1990年代末的部分
这里也确实是这样说的
并且在第一份文档中正确地定义了这一点
所以很明显这在工作不可能凭空捏造这些信息
这意味着我们的rage已经成功设置好了
我可以尽可能多的提问
但现在让我们看看
有没有什么不在react中的问题
例如
我们可以说open night在2024年表现如何
retriever工具被回调到模型
看这个
如果我这样做文档没有提供具体的信息
这是真的
因为OpenAI不是一家上市公司
没错
他回答正确了
因此也没有幻觉
你可以清楚地看到
这完全没问题
女士们
先生们
这就是如何在line graph中创建一个检索
增强生成rag图
太棒了好了各位
这就到了本课程的结尾了
我希望你喜欢它
我希望你学到了很多关于land graph的知识
虽然本课程在这里结束了
但你在land graph的旅程才刚刚开始
想想你能做出多少酷炫的AI项目
AI减智能体系统
也许你也可以做出自己的贾维斯
如果你对课程内容或任何其他事情
有任何进一步的问题
或者只是想打个招呼
随时可以在link定上给我发消息
说到这里
非常感谢你观看本课程
我希望能在另一个课程中见到你
保重